jesse smilet is going to jail he was in
the courtroom and he was ranting and he
was saying i'm not crazy institution
you're the one no uh what actually
happened was he was sentenced to 150
days in jail 30 months of probation and
then he yelled out that he's not
suicidal and that he didn't do it and
now everyone's making a meme about it so
juicy smoolier will be in jail we'll
talk about that we got a bunch of crazy
news man facebook's basically getting
rid of their rules facebook says you're
allowed to call for violence so long as
it's against russians and vladimir putin
i'm i'm wondering if youtube will allow
that too cause then you know what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna abuse that i'm gonna
i'm gonna abuse it like crazy i'm gonna
be like i'm gonna say i'm gonna say it
i'm gonna say okay but until we get the
the go ahead from youtube that were that
the rules no longer apply so long as
you're calling for the death of a
russian well
isn't it crazy that's where we're at
we've also got uh the censorship getting
absolutely insane duckduckgo has
announced they'll be censoring their
search feed basically destroying their
entire value proposition with a single
tweet
and then here's where it gets crazy the
hill got censored
that's just absolutely nuts so we'll
talk about that and joining us to
actually uh um clarifies to what
happened why the hell got censored is
kim iverson hi thanks for having me yeah
so who are you what are you doing um
well i'm kim and i'm on the hills rising
i also have my own youtube channel and
also on rumble and locals and all those
other places and whatnot so but yeah we
just um i'm here in the dc area because
i came back i was actually supposed to
be here on monday
to be in studio for the hills rising
which i've been hosting since
last july but because of covid we i
wasn't in the studio the other two hosts
were in the studio ryan graham and um
robbie suave and we've had a rotating
castle post this whole time but they
wanted me to come into the studio then
we had to postpone the trip because
suddenly we got the notification that
the channel had been suspended for
reporting the news for reporting the
news seven day suspension no uploading
of content no live streaming this is the
hill this is a major news organization
and the entire channel was suspended and
it was because what had happened was the
channel a year ago had actually aired um
so we have rising on the channel but
then also the hill just airs footage and
there's no commentary there's no host
it's not a podcast or anything like that
it's just raw footage like c-span style
and uh a year ago they aired raw footage
from cpac
and some of the some of the speeches
that were at cpac and they got a strike
for doing that
and then um b being a news organization
the hill said you know we're airing more
cpac so they aired cpac this year raw
footage again did it again thinking
we're a news organization we should be
able to air footage from what would be
newsworthy speeches
and then rising
um did a segment about trump talking on
laura ingram's show
talking about vladimir putin how he's a
genius i don't know if you saw that clip
yeah yeah and
in that clip he says something you know
he he says things says things about the
election though right we all and we know
he always says he's he makes the same
claims over and over and over again
right as a trump thing to do and he made
a claim and
the because the segment on rising was
about what he said about vladimir putin
and it was about ukraine no one on the
panel no one in the discussion
immediately said that fake you know that
is a fact check and it popped in and
immediately fact checked the claim which
is what you have to do according to
youtube's
guidelines their election misinformation
guidelines as you have to immediately in
real time
say
that is not true you know what he's
saying is fake news
well nobody did that this is the current
state of media but it's okay it's okay
if you're calling for the death of
russians
now facebook says that's good so we'll
talk about that twitter clearly must
allow that as well yes
well i mean they allowed it already so
but uh i also want to talk to you about
you you raised you tweeted recently
about voting straight ticket republican
so we'll get into all that that was
interesting and uh but we'll do it we
also have sheamus hanging out i am here
on the show tonight glad to be back i
run a youtube channel called freedom
tunes for those of you who are not
familiar with me in my work we just
released a cartoon today about the
genocide in yemen that the united states
government has been funding the saudis
to carry out so if you guys want to
check that out it's it's pretty
informative and uh engaging and
hopefully you'll learn a bit more about
the conflict
uh and i'm ian crossland and just before
i forget i'm looking for an open source
uh ux designer if someone out there
wants to get involved with our charity
that we're setting up and work on this
project that me and tim have been
building for the last year uh with a
great team of developers we're getting
to the point where we have a lot of the
back end done and we're going to start
making the front end look beautiful so
if you want to connect with me do it on
twitter or with mines and i'll rope you
in and i can talk more about that later
so hit me up
i know a russian that might be oh yeah
yeah all people are welcome yeah and i'm
also here in the corner pushing buttons
very excited for tonight's conversation
love kim very smart input i'm stoked
before we get started my friends we have
an awesome sponsor head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com and you can get
virtual shield a virtual private network
with a 50
lifetime discount a virtual private
network is a basic layer of security for
you while you're browsing the internet
and i think it's particularly important
right now especially based on everything
we've seen with the january 6 committee
they've been filing subpoenas against
people's phone records i should actually
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm wrong about that
they straight up went to these companies
and they just give us their records and
they were like okay and so they're
giving people's private information away
one thing you can do to make sure that
you are not having your information just
given away use a vpn if you go to
surfing internet safe you will get 50
off virtual shield says their vpn
service is compatible with all devices
and allows you to browse the web safely
securely and anonymously using their
global network of servers and private
ips
they say that when using their vpn
service your traffic is routed through
their secure and encrypted servers this
means that any restrictions censorship
or blocks on your internet are bypassed
and that one's particularly relevant now
with censorship and blocks and things
like that
you can enjoy browsing on a fast
reliable secure and always available
network it's completely free for 30 days
available on mac windows iphone ipad
android and chrome virtual shield does
all the work your entire connection
becomes secure private and encrypted
personal family and business plans are
available family plan includes 15
devices business plan allows you to add
as many employees as you need and
virtual shield will completely encrypt
your wi-fi connection blocking hackers
and everyone else from accessing any of
your data virtual shield the first
sponsor that we've ever had here at
timcast are eternally grateful head over
to surfing internetsafe.com pick that up
today but also don't forget go to
timcast.com become a member support us
directly if you missed it yesterday was
my birthday and if you still want to
give me that birthday present
i accept go to timcast.com be a member
and uh we really do appreciate it you
help keep our journalists employed
they're reporting every day we have on
the ground reporters as well and we are
expanding you'll also get access to our
exclusive members only segments which
are going to have up tonight around 11
or so p.m so you'll not want to miss
that
but let's just get straight into that
news smash the like button subscribe to
the channel all that good stuff here it
is ladies and gentlemen the moment you
have all been waiting for
jesse smilet sentenced to 150 days in
jail
30 months of probation and here's the
best part
following the sentencing he screamed i
am not suicidal and i did not do it he's
also going to have to pace the city of
chicago 120 000 in restitution and was
fined 25 000
so he's still
saying he's innocent i think his life is
basically over but
well he clearly thinks so too yeah yeah
otherwise he wouldn't have yelled out
i'm not suicidal he thinks he's going to
get
abstained i think you're going to be
fine jesse yeah that's really sad i
don't think the guy planning on like
killing himself and making it seem like
someone else did it that's insane who
would who would be trying to kill him
what kind of paranoia would lead him to
think that anyone out there is trying to
suicide him in prison now we're getting
into crazy conspiracy territory because
there was already crazy conspiracy
theories around his what he did because
at the time those two uh nigerian trump
supporters attacked him so he claimed
and he still asserts his innocence uh
kamala harris was advocating for this
lynching bill which i believe just
passed yeah it did pass yeah
yeah yeah a lot of people were like
isn't that weird that this thing
happened to smell at the same time and
he's friends with these people
ah
look i think the guy was staging a hoax
to bolster his career yes you know why
you don't need to draw a bigger
conspiracy than that you know what i
mean but for him to come out and scream
he's not suicidal when the conspiracy
was already that he was like colluding
with democrats to pass laws or whatever
which is
a bit absurd you know in and of itself
maybe he's playing that up maybe he's
trying to make people think that you
know i don't know there's a conspiracy
against him or something he strikes me
as a really really scared person yeah
you know in general yeah he can also
obviously just be completely insane i
don't know but that's just a very
bizarre response the dude's clearly
insane well not i mean if you're going
into pr for one it's scary to go to
prison right so of course he's extremely
scared and he doesn't know what's going
to happen to him you worry about your
safety when you're going to prison but i
don't know if it has to be some super
big conspiracy of thinking oh the
government's after me or it's somebody
you know and they're going to epstein me
in prison or something i mean i think it
could just be as simple as people are
angry with him for staging a crime when
there's real racism in the world and
he's now faking it in order to get
attention and it upsets people that's a
good point he might just go to jail and
there might be some guy who's like you
have set us back yeah you know how many
years with civil rights and just be like
he's not going to prison he's going to
jail so if he's in chicago i think he
might go to county over at like 26 in
california i think that's where it's at
which is really bad he's not going to go
away for that very long though 150 days
he's going to be he's going to be out
i mean how long do you think he's going
to actually serve of 150 days but of
that that felony charge he can't travel
anymore it's gonna be really difficult
for him to travel internationally so
here's my understanding about chicago i
don't know i think they'll put him in
cook county jail i think it's at 26 in
california it's on the south side my
what i'm told from all the people who
are down there
you're probably going to be fine it's a
pretty bad spot but everyone's scared
because when you're there in illinois
you can only go to jail for just under
one year so 364 days if you hit 365 they
tran you have to go to prison so prison
is a year more and this is my
understanding i could be wrong about
this so for people who are at cook
county just in jail they're like hey man
i don't any trouble man i'm going to get
out you know what i mean don't don't
don't screw around because they'll
charge you with something and then push
it longer and then send you to like
joliet or something like that
i think he's going to be fine
i think he's going to go to jail and
he's going to complain about it
him screaming he's not suicidal to me
sounds more like a spoiled rich guy yeah
who doesn't know what real hardship is
and he's probably freaking out like oh
man oh they're going to kill me in
prison yeah that's fair that's probably
more yeah
some of the quotes from the judge one is
your very name has become an adverb for
lying
you were throwing a national pity party
for yourself i i didn't listen to it yet
but this is uh well he's not wrong no
well here's my question you guys 150
days in jail
too long no just too long no not for a
federal crime like this the guy i don't
think it was federal was it really
it was just like this felony a felony
that's a difference that's okay federal
is like when you cross state lines into
it okay no no it was it was multiple
felonies it was definitely felonious i
mean i don't care who you are
at some point well i guess if you're the
president it's not illegal but at some
point
because it copycats will come along and
do what he did if they don't punish the
guy
i don't there's got to be another way to
punish him than just jail i mean i know
we're a society that just really loves
to incarcerate people but i just think
that there's maybe another way i mean
this guy's not a danger to anyone and we
have overcrowding in prisons we we
incarcerate everybody for everything and
i just think certain crimes when you're
not in actual danger i mean i'm not
afraid of this guy if i cross him in the
street
what is he going to do to me nothing
what is he going to do to you i mean i
understand i think he should pay for
what he's done
but i think there's maybe another way to
do it than to just incarcerate yeah he's
not physically violent of physical
violent threat but his mind is dangerous
because he got cops to waste their time
and take them away from people that
could have needed their help totally
exactly and i mean as a rich celebrity
paying a fine is it necessarily going to
be the worst thing in the world for them
this is someone who literally just
smeared half of the country by
insinuating that because they were trump
supporters they wanted to hurt him and
that it's a fact that there are just
these roving trump supporters going
around the country and democrat-run
cities like chicago trying to lynch
people at two in the morning so so how
about he gets sentenced to
uh
attending every trump rally right
or like public shaming like they do in
china but you should try
here's the thing that would provide them
with so many opportunities to come up
with fake hate crime stories and the
democrats would believe every single one
they'd be like just cause he lied once
doesn't mean these other ones aren't
true there's got to be something else
though there's i'm going to agree with
you education camps for some reason i
was watching 60 days in last night this
reality show i'd never heard of until
last night about people going undercover
into prison and i was like it's it's
real it's like finally i've never been
in prison and i didn't really
understand what it is until last night
i'm starting to get an idea of how stuck
together all these people are in the
higher immediate you get in and it's
like just gang warfare basically oh yeah
i don't think it's good for people like
jesse it doesn't make sense no and
there's other ways to punish people
other than right now it is just prison
or fines i mean i'm saying there are
other ways and there's other countries
that have figured out other ways and
then we would just have to have a
discussion on how moral they are why is
there one thing particularly well like
china literally just did a public
shaming event where they made the people
they marched them down the street and
they had to wear
signs
and there was a parade of people looking
at them and the sign you know said what
they had done and there was yeah so
here's the thing yeah well i'm not
saying that's exactly what we would do
but we would have some discussion on
what would be the ethical or moral thing
to do that doesn't involve necessarily
prison or a fine you know get out of
jail free card or get out of a jail
for 18 years of hard labor and i would
like rocks well i mean in the united
states we have a much more uh humane
method of public humiliation where we
take people who are never given a trial
and then our media just smears them for
arguing against the narrative that's
great well that's what they argued like
his defense attorney said that he's
already had his reputation and life
destroyed he suffered exactly and of
course i'm not trying to make light of
of china their tactics for punishment
but jesse smallett has clearly been
publicly publicly humiliated at the end
of this thing he yells out i didn't do
it yeah yeah like come on
that's a very good point he hasn't
accepted responsibility for the crime
yet it's hard to be sympathetic to him
right he should go to jail until he
admits that he did it oh my gosh and now
we're talking i'm absolutely joking
about all right
all you got to do is say you didn't you
can go home yeah that's fine i did it oh
you're going to present now you
confessed oh you know the thing about
jail
i think they're completely broken
sending you know you get these young men
they'll go to prison for some petty
crime or some like some relatively minor
offense but enough to warrant prison and
then they come out hardened they come
out
just mixing all of these people who are
of a criminal element
so i don't know what the answer is but i
think the reason we just do president
fines is because we have we you're not
allowed to engage the u.s cannot engage
in cruel and unusual punishment so
unusual simply means
out of the ordinary we need to have a
set system which like everybody has to
be you know abide by the same kind of
punishment
the problem i suppose is we've grown to
view prison as punishment or retribution
instead of rehabilitation
people want justice and to most people
they want you to suffer
and that's a problem you know there's a
video i watched it's crazy this guy
murders this young girl
he's in court
and he's sitting there and he's like a
serial killer and this was like a viral
video on reddit and all of these people
are yelling at him like you're a monster
and what you've done and he's just
stoned face the whole time and then
finally like this guy comes up and he's
like i forgive you for what you've done
and then the murderer just starts
bawling and crying and freaking out and
it's like
man maybe maybe we need to uh
we need to reassess as a society what
our goals are with people who break the
law so i hear what you're saying and i
place a lot of emphasis and value on
forgiveness as a christian i think it's
unbelievably important but we also can't
engage in a kind of false mercy which
refuses to punish crime because then
what happens is more people commit
crimes against innocent victims and
there's more human suffering generated
overall i don't know if that's true i
think it is yeah if there are no
criminal punishments for for crimes of
course people are going to be more
likely to commit crimes you're going to
have more innocent victims who are
harmed i mean i i agree that you have to
have punishment for a crime but i don't
know if saying well we're going to
punish you know we're going to
criminalize the more we criminalize then
something will be you'll be deterred
from doing it because we've criminalized
it i mean we've seen evidence of that
not being the case it depends i mean
look i know a lot of people who are
afraid to go to any kind of protest
event because of the way the united
states government has come down on
people for the january 6th events even
though they hadn't even done anything
violent so people are afraid of prison
time including people who aren't doing
anything wrong or planning on doing
anything wrong i think they start off
that way i agree i think that there is a
chilling effect at first but then people
start to relax a little bit and they
figure out way workarounds and then they
start doing those workarounds i think it
can happen again i mean i would argue
that prison time or the potential for
prison time is a pretty strong incentive
against committing a crime i also agree
with you that it's not perfect and it's
a very complicated system because the
united states does have a very large
share of prisoners compared to other
countries i don't exactly know what the
solution to that problem is but i i do
think punishment is not necessarily a
bad thing i got it yes compromise
between the left and the right we
abolish prisons
and prison sentences
and we abolish the atf and all gun laws
there you go
problem solved
no deal no deal all the criminals can
leave and i can walk around new york
city armed and that that's a that's a
compromise
and i will say this about the prison
system one unbelievably massive glaring
problem is the how rampant sexual
assault is behind bars in many places
and how that isn't really something
that's sorted out and i think there's a
good argument to be made that knowing
that someone is likely to be sexually
assaulted in prison and then sending
them sending them there could be argued
to be a cruel and unusual punishment
it's not exactly the same because you're
not guaranteed it's going to happen but
most people are afraid of going to
prison for that specific reason i don't
know if we've ever cared about cruel and
unusual punishment when it comes to
prisons i mean for goodness sakes we
electrocuted people for a long time do
you know how barbaric that sounds i mean
just looking back who was the guy that
thought was to kill him though right
well it's yeah so that's and that we
thought for whatever reason that that
was a good idea a humane idea a moral or
ethical idea to electrocute a person to
death well look when there are other
ways to kill a person look at lethal
injection right what's what's the idea
behind lethal injections humane there i
was reading one study that said
lethal injection and maybe this is wrong
so you know i'm not an expert on this
the they give you three injections i'm
pretty sure three different drugs the
first one paralyzes you right because
the next one's excruciatingly painful
and they don't want you to be able to
show it yeah so still you know are there
any are there any states that allow
firing squad there should be utah utah's
firing squad yeah i'm opposed to the
death penalty outright 100 so i don't
you know think any we should be killing
people at all but you know yeah part of
this conversation is like punishing cr
crime i kind of agree but then who
decides what's legal and what's not
legal that's the danger the legislative
bodies of america yeah or the executive
order or something like that and they're
like now walking on the left side of the
street is illegal and if you did it
yesterday you're you're retroactively
guilty well let's not give them ideas
please i don't know that's that's crazy
so like this is an excellent i don't
know
this is an excellent exact evil yes this
is an excellent segue into this other
story we were initially going to lead
with this one then the juicy smoothie
stuff broke but check this out reuters
says facebook temporarily allows posts
on ukraine war calling for violence
against invading russians or putin's
death
that to me is absolutely amazing they
say
meta platforms will allow facebook and
instagram users in some countries to
call for violence against russian and
russian soldiers russians and russian
soldiers civilians and soldiers holy
moly in the context of the ukraine
invasion what does that mean what does
that mean does that mean you can be like
i just plain don't like the invasion and
then say just kill civilians or
something like every russian should pay
yes right until until when you know the
thing that i don't understand about all
of these sanctions and even just these
ideas that you've got to take it out on
russians and i even saw this video that
was circulating of this group in canada
that was
painting they were they were
vandalizing a russian community center
you know with and they were painting all
over it blue and yellow and it's just
okay if if we in the west continue to
assert and believe that vladimir putin
is a dictator and that he isn't that
they don't live in a democracy then why
would we take anything out on the people
what what purpose is that because you'd
only do that if you think the people are
then going to turn around and pressure
their government or you're punishing
them for voting that government in like
they were a democracy and look at the
bad choice you people made but if you
don't believe it's a democracy then what
are you doing well so the reason i think
this was an excellent segue from the
previous uh segment ian was talking
about how there could be an executive
decree like okay now this thing is is
not allowed anymore in this instance
we're seeing what happened happens when
we end up in corporatocracy where our
social discussions our society is being
ruled by technocrats in silicon valley
who change the rules on a whim mark
zuckerberg apparently mark zuckerberg
apparently they'll say you can't do
these things they're against the rule
and then when they want to enact massive
societal change they'll come out and be
like you are now allowed peasants do as
we say yeah
that's creepy yeah well i see calling
for violence against invading russians
that's not what it is no no no russians
and russian soldiers in the context of
ukraine invasion
what that
it depends on what it means so we'll
have to see the exact policy they say as
a result of the russian invasion of
ukraine we have temporarily made
allowances for some for forms of
political expression that would normally
violate our rules like violent speech
such as quote death to russian invaders
we still won't allow credible calls for
violence against russian civilians okay
that's an important objection except
who's a russian invader
right the russian military what about a
guy who's like invalid vladivostok who's
like chilling in a boat
so now like the guy making the steel
like in in the middle of the country
that is getting shipped to make the
tanks you know he's part of the war
machine now even though he's a civilian
but they're pretty clear that they don't
want to target civilians
but again the definition of a civilian
is work it's really muddy and that's
what's going on even with the war you
know when they're talking about oh these
civilians are being killed in ukraine
and it's like well okay but what do you
classify who do you classify as a
civilian when they're conscripting
everybody giving them a gun telling them
to fight so if every male 18 to 60 years
old is given a weapon and told to go
fight now his civilization is no longer
but i think they might be counting them
as civilians for sure i agree but you'd
what you'd have to call the militia
you'd have to say like you know russians
kill 12 militia they're not doing that
because it's all a big propaganda
machine sure this this this stuff scares
me because
it sounds some people would argue it's
reasonable oh but we're talking about
war and violence and i'm like i don't
care
you know we have two problems here one i
don't think you should be calling for
the death of people i think you can say
we're being invaded i will defend myself
and defend my country that i understand
but to be like i am calling for the
death of this group or whatever the
other issue is that
the rules of our society and what ideas
are allowed are being dictated by
technocrats who are unelected now that's
a scary prospect you want to claim
vladimir putin as bad as a dictator i'll
be like sure what about our society
being dominated by facebook and google
how much industry is digital now
how many people have jobs that are based
on youtube or facebook or or twitter or
whatever and these companies but my
private platforms they can just
eliminate you from your entire job
gone in an instant because they decided
it but do you think they're the ones
deciding or do you think the politicians
are pressuring them
because then it really does become a
first amendment issue when if they're
making policy decisions based on the
pressure they're getting from
politicians because they're afraid of
regulation
i think it's both
yeah that was my thought too
both it just seems like from a platform
perspective you'd want no regulation
whatsoever you'd want just people to say
whatever and you wouldn't care because
that brings more people to your platform
yeah so
my biggest question is who would be
wanting to make it so that you can say
this about russia well well hold on yeah
we have an update we have we have new
answers
the temporary policy changes on calls to
violence calls for violence to russian
soldiers applies to armenia azerbaijan
estonia georgia hungary latvia lithuania
poland romania russia silva russia
slovakia and ukraine according to an
email that means if you're a russian
citizen in russia you can be calling for
the death of your own military if you
are polish nato country or lithuania or
latvia or estonia you can call for death
it's very interesting very weird yeah
zuckerberg for sure wants ukraine to win
the war i mean he's bought into the
propaganda and he's an ideologue yeah i
don't think it's zuckerberg personally
he makes all the decisions did we have
the administration actively pressuring
social media companies to remove vaccine
misinformation we know that the united
states government isn't above doing this
kind of thing however i will say to your
point asking about uh whether zuckerberg
could have any motivation to avoid
regulation it's interesting because
facebook has actually been pushing for
certain regulations surrounding speech
codes online i think it might actually
be advantageous for them in some ways
depending upon what the legislation is
because then people aren't angry with
them as a comp for as a company when
they ban people and they won't be likely
to go to competitors they'll just see it
as a large overarching thing and then
those regulations that facebook loves
the place in its terms of service become
policy for the entire country so small
people who might compete with facebook
by having a more free speech platform
won't be able to do so
or they're just trying to get into the
china market that's possible as well
absolutely i actually think that's
really what's going on with google
twitter and facebook as they're trying
to get into the china market and they
were banned back in 2011 china said you
can't come into our country because
you're not willing to censor and their
response was we're an american company
we have american values we don't censor
and now that's obviously changed yeah
censorship
it's here man it's coming yeah more than
five dot go announce it we'll get into
that in a little bit yeah they just
destroyed themselves terrible yeah
that's what i use why would i use
duckduckgo ever again after this what's
the better search engine i don't know
brave brave has their own rave oh it
does
somewhat someone tweeted that
but uh you know i wanna we'll stay a
little bit focused on on this because
there's another bit of news related to
this we talked about with imagine nawaz
facebook previously allowed you to
praise
uh one nazi group the azov battalion so
if you were if you were actively
praising nazis on facebook so long it
was the ukrainian soldiers that was a
lot crazy
they're afraid of the swastika but not
nazism just the swastikas although they
have a swastika it's like that diagonal
one yeah and it's like half a swastika
as a battalion yeah yeah yeah but
facebook is like okay this time it's
fine that's so crazy that's crazy the
enemy of my enemy is my friend all of
these people putting the ukrainian flags
in their profiles who just last month
were like we got to fight the fascists
are now like well these fascists
is crazy when nawaz was here he pointed
out that what's happening is people from
around the world are going to join azov
to fight and then they're becoming
radicalized and learning how to fight is
this with a terrorist group and then
they're going to go home
radicalized and create their own little
pockets of azov or nazism or whatever
that's his fear
he's i guess he's seen it before i mean
it's not uncommon it's an interesting
isis too well we already saw this sort
of you know this is just another proxy
war that we're having with russia right
now in ukraine and it actually mimics a
lot what we did in um you know this is
the new afghanistan get out of one war
to start another you know just got to
replace the afghanistan war and this is
very similar to what happened in
afghanistan in the 80s because what the
us government was doing the carter
administration started and then it
continued on with reagan was was funding
the mujahideen yep and that they were
fighting the russians because the
russians were with the with the at the
time the afghan government brought in
the russian military to fight and the
mujahideen was fighting against the
russians we armed the mujahideen we
trained them we didn't go in we didn't
fight the russians specifically we let
them do it and they were battling their
own country they were trying to get
their own country back from the soviets
right freedom fights and we boasted that
we had given russia their own vietnam
yeah by entangling them yes because it
was well understood that the vietnam war
was horrible for america both in terms
of foreign policy and domestic policy
right because this country started to
fall apart and there was a lot of
cultural turmoil as a result and so he
said if we could give one of those to
russia it would sure help based on the
collapse of the ussr keep in mind when
you when terrorists work for your com
country they're called freedom fighters
that's what yeah
and we saw what happened to the
mujahideen al
had been like killing russians for tens
of thousands of russians over the last
five or eight years or something wasn't
like 14 000. well 14 000 people have
been killed in the dunba in the civil
war between the separatists and the
dunbas region and
um and the government because you know
there's an area of ukraine that has been
controlled by these separatists since
2014 and during the civil war conflict
which you know we call in the west we
say that they are russian-backed
um freedom you know russian-backed
separatists really they're ukrainians
fighting ukrainians in a civil war and
there's been 14 000 fatalities there but
a lot of them have been this battalion
and these sort of um
very you know not i mean really there's
no way to say it other i mean these are
not like far right these are actual
nazis um and they have been doing a lot
of that doing a lot of this battle but
you know hillary clinton even came out
like to a week and a half ago i think
that she was giggling about well you saw
how it worked out in uh afghanistan for
the soviets when you know you saw how
well that happened because they
ultimately had to back out of
yeah that was afterwards that was in the
80s in the mountains now we're talking
about flat land in 2020s but it's still
a similar thing we're arming a group
we're giving them a bunch of weapons
this group ideologically is
is very you know it is they're not
aligned with really democratic values
western values fundamentally but we're
still saying oh but you're our friends
now because you're fighting our enemy
and that's exactly what happened in the
mujahideen in afghanistan and that did
not turn out well ultimately we ended up
in a war in afghanistan that we could
not win and we've been in the middle
east this entire time and so to your
point with we're you know then they're
recruiting all of these fighters that
are coming in from every other european
country and they're very far-right
radical people that are going to fight
alongside these battalions and yeah
we're arming them helping them out and
who knows what that will reel into 20
years from now i mean how long did it
take for the mujahideen to turn into al
qaeda
and then you know all and taliban it
could very well happen that ukraine is
split the east goes to the russia the
west goes to azov and we've got a nazi
country basically that's that's i think
exactly what's going to happen i don't
know if it'll go to them specifically
yeah i think the west will go to nato eu
right but they'll have the those the
battalion in there i mean they'll be
part of
well i don't i don't know you know i
think when you look at isis it's i'll
just say this my opinion the west
clearly wanted isis to function because
it was destabilizing syria
the u.s wanted syria they wanted us the
assad regime to fall so that the u.s
could get their pipeline up to displace
the russian gas monopoly so isis is
there and it's like oh no oh we can't
stop i saw jesus and then trump comes in
he's like flatten them wipes isis out
that's actually a problem for the west
for you know nato the us and cia because
then what's going to cause syria to fall
yeah azov they need another boogeyman so
if the us gets so right now
the us
has a as of if russia takes ukraine then
all of a sudden you might see this
rampant destructive nazi battalion and
the u.s will be like oh this is so oh
it's so bad and somehow they'll end up
with u.s trucks and vehicles and weapons
yes absolutely oh well oh we have to
fight that rebel group that we funded a
while ago that's so crazy that we have
to fight the nazis
you ever see the isis the video of the
isis guys in the truck and it's got like
jim's plumbing from detroit michigan on
the side of it or something i think
that truck there were pictures from
syria that came out that had a kid
wearing one of my high school's gym
shirts on it because someone had donated
their gym shirts and other clothing to
some other organization it ended up in
their hands so it was like let's let's
talk about surreal let's talk about how
where the censorship is going we got the
story on duckduckgo this is uh gabriel
weinberg who is the ceo and founder of
duckduckgo he tweeted like so many
others i am sickened by russia's
invasion so i've decided to completely
and totally destroy my company no one
should ever use it again it's a garbage
i'm just kidding he didn't say that he
actually might as well
exactly he said like so many others i am
sickened by russia's invasion of ukraine
and that gigantic humanitarian crisis
can it continues to create at duckduckgo
we've been rolling out search updates to
downrank sites associated with russian
disinformation this all makes sense now
in addition to downranking sites
associated with this information we also
often place news modules and information
box at the top of duckduckgo search
results dr go's mission is to make
simple privacy protection
yeah no that's not your value
proposition dudes so i have a question
for you gabriel um
who determines what's russian
disinformation who determines what's
true and do you have like who at
uh go is the the arbiter of truth and
and morality so i can better understand
what sites you've decided to
is completely download at this point i
don't see why anybody would use them and
they are because these last you know now
this is making sense to me because as
i've been trying to do some research
about the conflict that's going on and
trying to get truth because we know it's
a big propaganda problem um i've been
going from google to duckduckgo and
getting the exact same search results
and being very frustrated by it because
i rely on duckduckgo to give me
you know search results that are
different from different sites than the
ones that google just gives me yeah
absolutely no i mean for a very long
time duckduckgo is far superior to
google when i do work with the
foundation for economic education to
create these educational cartoons we'll
usually have people at their
organization who will do some research
for us if i don't have the time to dive
into all of it and there was a topic
that we needed to dive into and i can't
remember exactly what it was but the
fellow who was doing research kept
saying i can't really find anything
about this on google and he'd been
searching for hours and i said oh just
try duckduckgo and within 15 minutes he
had like 10 links with a lot of really
great information in them and it's just
sad that that resource isn't really a
reliable one take a look at this tweet
right here duckduckgo tweeted on april 6
2019. quote when you search you expect
unbiased results but that's not what you
get on google and that is a quote from
that same guy gabriel weinberg
he's now like privacy is the reason
people use duckduckgo no
no people use dr.go because they know
google is censoring information yeah all
right well there's the brave search
people are highlighting brave is
available so everybody switch on over
and we'll keep playing this game of cat
mouse
maybe we should let this guy know that
he just killed his business tweet on him
i think he's gonna figure it out yeah i
you know what i should log in on twitter
so that i could actively do that during
the show be like gabriel you have but i
did already basically tweet that i said
it duckduckgo i said duckduckgo destroys
their only value proposition with a
single tweet
yeah completely
used to typing duckduckgo and instead of
google because it was such a habit for
me that i'd formed over many years of
exclusively using google before i knew
that they were terrible and duckduckgo
is a terrible website name to be
complete yeah yeah i know is not good
brand we should have if this guy ceo
wants to come on and and defend himself
maybe the cia gave him a gag order and
was like you're going to be censoring
information now and you're not allowed
to talk about why you think he would
tell you that yeah not on him he might
tell ian i mean he's in a lot of people
tell me
so
there was this uh email service see if
you guys can can look this up while i'm
talking about it where they got what's
called the national security letter they
had encrypted email uh was it something
forge or something i can't remember they
they said that i think it was like an s
the nsa contacted him and said it's a
national security letter you're not
allowed to tell anybody about this turn
over all this information and he was
like nope
and then they were like if you don't do
this you're getting in trouble and then
he went public and was like i got this
letter they're demanding i turn over
information on my clients
and then you know basically i think they
basically shut down his entire company
so this guy's probably chilling and he's
sitting there thinking like we're doing
a great job of fighting censorship and
there's a knock on the door and there's
a guy in nsa you know badge and he's
like you are from now on going to be
censoring information we don't like and
he goes you've got a boss and then he
goes to his twitter account he's like we
don't like free information we want
censorship there you go run with them
centralized power you do not want as a
tech leader you do not want centralized
control of your organization man because
you are the target you got to
decentralize that no one person should
be able to to change
a search engine like that in my opinion
it's way too dangerous people can get
co-opted
yep let me see i think i think i found
this story uh dude is this it from 2013.
2013 story how the government killed a
secure email company well i don't know
if this is the same company but they say
in mid-july tanya lakshina deputy
director for human rights human rights
watch moscow office wrote on her
facebook wall that she had received yes
it was lava bit there you go an email
from edward snowden at lavabit it
requested that she attend a press
conference at moscow's
chairman uh
to share medieval international airport
prizes
to discuss the nsa leaker situation
yesterday lava bit went dark an
encrypted statement posted on its
website the services owners and operator
ladder levitz ladar levison wrote i
cannot share my experience over the last
six weeks even though i have twice made
the appropriate requests those
experiences led him to shut down the
service rather than as he put it become
complicit in crimes against the american
people lava users reacted with consumer
vitriol on the company's facebook page
what about our emails the tide quickly
turned toward government critique by the
end of the night a similar service
silent circle also shut down its
encrypted email product calling the
lavabit affair the writing on the wall
so clarification
he refused to give in to the government
and shut it down rather than turn over
people's information good for him yeah
that's great and maybe that's what
happened with duckduckgo
maybe they should they knock on your
door one day and they're like well we
can destroy you and everything you love
and own or you can bend the knee and do
as you're told welcome to the empire
yeah it's been so good to you your whole
life now bow well then what you wouldn't
never i mean either way his business is
dead so you might as well have your
dignity seriously yeah
man i would have i'd love to be the ceo
of duckduckgo i'm not saying this
actually happened we don't know for sure
but i tell you this if i was the ceo of
this company and then i got a knock on
the door and they're like we want you to
censor information from russian sources
i'd be like no and they would like you
have to and i beg how about i just shut
it down and then then what what are they
gonna do about it and then i'd go public
and be like hey guys the government's
requesting we send her information so
i'm shutting it down
that being said elon musk yep was
publicly he publicly stated he will
never censor information over starlink
so except at gunpoint
but dude's got
you know some people say there's a thing
called fu money yeah elon musk has
something like f everyone money like did
he literally say i would at gunpoint
yeah while he's just inviting gunpowder
though you know i'm trying to use this
brave search it's in beta it's not great
yet that's the downside like i'm gonna
go well i'm gonna go home i was said
later i'm gonna go home later after the
show and get on my computer my desktop
and i've got duckduckgo and google
search
if i really need a good search engine
that can crawl the web i need something
that's tried and true duckduckgo has
been it is my current default me too so
now i have to switch it because i'm not
going to support that yeah like i'm
maybe i'll use it when i'm not searching
for
news but then go to brave when i'm
searching for data about russia i don't
know how this show exists
yeah because you're so charming
and you actually do your research
yeah i guess but like
i don't know man the government the
government the institutions the
establishment democrats and neocons are
trying so hard to drum up a war
in between nato and russia we've got 13
000 nato soldiers in estonia right now i
think in sonia and they're firing
stinger missiles and they're kamala
harris is in poland and she's saying
putin don't you dare we're coming it's
like that's the opposite of the
escalation they i i genuine i think the
the nato would love to get an excuse to
just flatten russia
and they're doing everything in their
power it seems and we're just sitting
here all talking like every night being
like that's bad that's wrong you
shouldn't do it they're lying to the
american people i just don't understand
why we haven't gotten our well we got
swatted six times this year yeah so
maybe that's happening i don't think i i
for one we've never tested nato right so
it's never really truly been tested so
article 5 has been called on one one
time after 9 11 right and the nato
forces what did they do after 9 11. they
said okay yeah i guess this qualifies
and they sent some jets over to patrol
the u.s skies because that's the only
job is they they have to defend you on
your soil they don't have to go to enemy
soil that's why they didn't go into
afghanistan iraq they did have some you
know some countries were able to opt in
but there wasn't an article five you
know actually invoked in order to force
uh troops to go in anywhere so it's
never really been tested we don't
actually know i mean we sit here and we
posture and we act like oh yeah we were
totally flat in russia but we don't
actually know how we would do
head-to-head against russia and we also
don't know who would join in with russia
and russia their military is i think
their capabilities around like what 50
60 percent of nato which sounds we don't
know that right right but i will say
this russia's military is unified under
one command structure nato is a bunch of
different countries different languages
different cultures that could be a huge
issue but nato's really only the united
states france the uk and turkey yeah
everybody else just what gives us some
bodies the bodies of people that maybe
are not well trained right so you have
to have
those four countries getting together
and the french are always lately they've
been pretty hesitant to get involved at
all they've got their own problems so
they especially don't like to go with
this to the middle east and turkey same
thing turkey feels a little bit hesitant
about that so and turkey
does is not really embraced very well
you know look look at how uh ukraine is
being embraced and putting in
applications to be joining the eu and
they get the backing of some eu members
and turkey's been applying year after
year after year let us into the eu and
they get snubbed so turkey is
one foot out the door right
i just
for russia and turkey not to be like
lockstep i can't imagine that black sea
you can't get through constantinople
continental you can't get through
istanbul without
without turkey well i think that's why
turkey knows that they've been embraced
by nato was just uh just to get just to
sort of uh
take some power away from russia
hopefully but turkey's not 100 there
with us i mean they really are
straddling the line between the two and
i think that at any minute turkey could
actually say you know what we just want
to forget this whole nato thing we're
not really involved in it historically i
mean people switch sides in the middle
of conflict it's not out of the ballpark
just because someone on paper says
they're your ally doesn't mean that like
when realism hits the fan people do what
they need to do to survive right that's
why nato hasn't really truly been tested
and i think they're afraid to actually
do it because i don't think they know
what turkey will actually do
if they'll really truly send bodies in
to go and confront russians and to
potentially you know to allow thousands
of your own to die for what
so
i just want to say we tested it speak of
the devil what was the full phrase
uh it looks like our chat shut down oh
what i noticed because you know we have
we have the live chat going and i can
see everything i got a little jinxed it
and uh normally it's just flying like
crazy just chats are coming in like
crazy and so i noticed it stopped moving
what and i was like what's this
there's no chat so i'm like maybe the
browser screwed up so i tried resetting
the chat didn't work i pulled up my
phone and went in there there's no chat
i just posted the message smash the like
button and i don't see it even on my own
phone on the same account so uh
it could be there we go
over the decade i noticed
almost all the time when people think
that you're doing something insidious
technically it's usually like a glitch
yeah no dude no way from my way from my
perspective as an admin it is a glitch
usually it's a glitch now
now it's now it's exploded they're like
he's on to us
some admins like people are saying chat
was dead it's back it's broken it's back
it could be a glitch you know the other
night my internet went down and other
people like my internet went down too
like two nights ago did you guys have
internet
did you guys have was there all sorts of
tech outages a couple nights ago like is
this like a global attack probably well
i wouldn't have been surprised
yeah yeah lo i'll i'll tell you this man
i think we're already in
world war iii the problem is people
don't like that phrase because it
invokes imagery of of bombings and
blitzkriegs and all that stuff but
people need to understand that nato is
absolutely supplying weapons and
personnel to the ukrainians for a war a
ground war with russia china has already
threatened the u.s that if we take any
any uh economic sanctions or actions
against them they'll retaliate against
us so
already china has announced that they're
going to be supporting russia with the
sanctions with union pay the us is
already
i'll put it this way what is war
can you define war for me like
legitimately like off top of your head
kim
two countries battling
maybe that you know because i'm not
trying to push on any country
how would you define it right we
typically where there's hot war there's
cold war there's economic warfare and
you can battle many ways you don't have
to battle with guns you could battle
with
like it could be cyber war
or you know any kind of really
economic warfare we've seen cyber
attacks across the board we've seen
weird outages happening we've seen
industrial plants exploding and things
like that and
if we're in an information warfare or an
infowar
some texas now you're really looking for
your chat to get shot you're talking
again
yeah no but but
i i think it's fair to say you know we
see all these stories where it's like
anonymous takes down russian
infrastructure and i'm like dude it's
probably the us government or its
contractors
it is western interests going after
russia here's here's what blows my mind
the us is like we want to give weapons
to the ukrainians right planes or
whatever poland says we want to give
these planes
if we're providing weaponry to
ukrainians
then latvia says we vote to allow our
citizens to go to ukraine and fight for
the ukrainians i'm like
how is this not a declaration of war
providing resources to one country who's
fighting another oh yeah and like visa
mastercard and american express shut
down axis in russia but it wasn't the
american government that did it so we're
off the hook
you know but it's like oh how much power
do these corporations have so think
about what is the purpose of war because
i i agree with you tim i actually think
we're in world war iii but i think we've
been and i actually i don't remember
which so i actually said that exact
thing on recently but um
but i think it's not because of the
weapons that we're giving and there's
battles going on in ukraine what is the
purpose of war
so when you're going to war with another
country why are you doing it
you're doing it because you're trying to
you don't want them to so we've always
we try to go to war with the soviets to
stop the spread of the soviet union
right so we don't want them to have
dominance or power
in certain parts of the world we want
influence over
different regions and people to our own
benefit right
so did you know february 4th did you
hear about this document that russia and
china put out together a statement
so they issued a statement february 4th
together
that it's a couple of pages long and it
if you read that statement that happened
before russia even invaded ukraine they
pretty much declare i mean it's the most
ominous statement because they
essentially come out declaring we're no
longer going to have a unipolar world it
is now multi-polar and these are that
yeah these this is how this is you know
this
basically pointing the finger at the
west almost blatantly that they don't i
don't know if they actually named the
united states in the document but they
essentially
they strongly allude saying
we're the reason why there isn't world
peace
that it's our fault and that the time
the things have changed this is it this
is the document the china aerospace
studies institute in their own words
joint statement of the russian
federation the people's republic of
china on the international relations
entering a new era of the of the global
sustainable development
well there you go
it's decently long i'm not going to read
the whole thing but no but there's parts
of it um that really they really call
out the american hegemony and when you
look at this and you think okay the
purpose of war is to stop the influence
or to
or to um weaken your enemy to some
degree
so war doesn't have to be with guns
and i think there's been a concerted
effort when you look at this and then
you look at the steps that russia has
taken and then you see the steps that
china has taken in response to it and
you realize that we might have been at
war china might have been at war with us
china and russia for a long time right
because really it's just about you have
an enemy you don't like the enemy you
want to harm the enemy in some way it
doesn't have to and they know they
couldn't beat us militarily nor did they
even want to
so they i think went after us
economically potentially yeah you want
con conquest or genocide i think are the
two main goals of war and it's usually
to empower yourself through the
destruction of the other um and that
doesn't have to be done with guns that
can be done psychologically like you see
children questioning their gender that's
basically
it's not genocide but if people stop
having babies that's the end of the
human rights it's control of a
population so
if you could take over a country without
firing a shot would you do it of course
nobody wants to waste resources right so
if you've got if you've got a country
that's got a bunch of nuclear reactors
do you want to blow them up or do you
want to use them you want to use them
anybody who's played the game
civilization knows this if you can take
over a city with minimal you know
bombings you get more from that city you
blow them up the population shrinks and
you get a crappier city just basic math
so they've been planning this for a long
time because they were trading in
dollars in 2014 i think the percentage
of dollars being traded between china
and russia was like 97
and now it's down to 30 something
percent that they use so they've been
doing that they've been making these
moves for a long time
they have been building up their own
economies strengthening their own ties
with one another they used to be enemies
now they're like best buddies
um and they've been making all of these
really really strategic moves making
friends around the world rather than
enemies
and now suddenly it's just really
strange to me
that russia decides to invade ukraine
when was it the 21st of february so they
issued this statement on the 4th russia
does a giant deal for a natural gas
pipeline
from ukraine to i mean from russia to
china giant pipeline and then suddenly
he goes in and invades ukraine like as
you know and i know a lot of it of
course they've been saying it's about
nato expansion but
why now were they gonna do a vote next
week to put ukraine into nato like
what's so different this week from last
week you see the video of the russian
politician in december saying february
22nd 2022 i wish this year would have
been peaceful but it's not gonna be mark
my words in december he said that and uh
that video is not getting a lot of play
but a lot of like i'm so a ukrainian
friend said that to me they were like
watch this video and then i was just
like whoa
so they knew they knew and uh truth be
told i didn't believe the us when they
were putting out these statements they
were like russia's going to do it
well look it's a democrat who cried
russia you know joe biden or jen sackey
or these democrats are like you know
nancy pelosi comes out and she's like
the russians are going to invade and i'm
like shut your mouth you liar i will not
believe a word that comes out of these
people's mouths and to our own detriment
what do you do
well they were right this one time
i mean it's like i said on yesterday's
show the moral of the story and the boy
who cried wolf was not oh those shameful
stupid villagers for not believing the
one time he turned out to be right the
moral of the story is it's his fault
because he lied consistently and lost
all credibility we should make uh uh we
should make
that kid's book the democratic cried
russian but the moral of the story is
you should always believe the democrats
no matter what when they're completely
wrong yeah so like it's the basic story
the bible cried wolfen in the end it's
just like if only they had just
continued to believe the little boy who
lied all the time they would have been
better off shows you to always obey the
authority that's true the authority is
never wrong
correct
yeah so what else is going on though i
mean we've been seeing china and russia
dumping us dollars for a long time now
and i remember conversations back in
like the late 2000s where they were like
china and russia are getting prepared
for a non-petro dollar non-us reserve
currency yeah it's going to like the how
do you say it the ewon you won uh they
saw the petro e1 is what they're moving
towards it sounds is that what i should
be buying right now
well maybe and isn't it so sad that the
elites in our country are so
unbelievably irresponsible and corrupt
that we don't even want to hold on to
our own currency because we all
basically believe it's going to collapse
and we're actively watching it lose
a large portion of its value yeah yeah
only eight percent that's what we're
being told i think it was march 2020
when they first did that print was it
1.2 trillion maybe it was april 2020
that was when i gave up on the us dollar
i was like wow okay i've known the
federal reserve's busted the economy and
the fiats nuts and that american
military-industrial complex is over
overreach but it never really struck me
until march 2020 like wow they're just
going to keep printing money it was um
what i understand it was that they were
giving
450 billion to the federal reserve to
leverage out in 4.5 trillion in loans
just completely flooding the market
the uh zubi tweeted this that the money
supply was 4 trillion in early 2020 and
now it's 20 trillion or something like
that or 23 trillion a lot of it's
because the savings accounts got
added to the money supply absolutely so
that's like half at least half i would
think of that no it's like it's like uh
it's more than half that number wow okay
okay but they did it to mask the amount
of printing because if you look at the
number the money supply is going along
all of a sudden they add the savings in
and then the money supply is increasing
at a new rate before when they added
it's like right when they added the
supply you see it china and russia saw
what happened in 2008 and they were like
you better start preparing because this
is the end when you look at the money
supply the real surge in money printing
happened right after that right after
2008 after the market crashed and then
with the epidemic it skyrockets yeah so
i think russia and china india brazil
probably a bunch of countries and i'm
sure the u.s even the united states yeah
you know well we i mean what happens is
they argue that we have to use
quantitative easing in order to
stimulate the economy but then we get
completely addicted because as soon as
you try quantitative tightening the
stock market goes crazy and we can't
have that happen so they just have to
continually inflate the currency to
prevent a crash
i posobik is a brilliant man jack pasok
and he constantly is like you do not
want the us dollar to not be the world
reserve currency i'm like i know i don't
but i also don't want to be living off
fiat for my grandchildren to suffer
under the slave boot of authoritarian
autocracy
you know and and have their lot have
their their their lives valued by some
corporate credit i don't know what to do
i don't want to destroy the system but
the system is an aberration and needs to
be rectified i think the best we can
hope for is the multi-polar world where
it's more of a east-west and so we're
not dominating the world with one
currency but instead there's one
currency that's often traded
in parts of the world and another that
is traded in the other part of the world
and you know as the world's population
has increased that's fine i mean when
you look at the population 70 years ago
compared to today i think it's doubled
on the globe so even if the dollar is
only dominant with half the world it's
still the same number of people as it
was
70 years ago but but have you considered
that um you know the average person i
should say all people actually are
are stupid and that we should control
them with a small council of elites who
who have inherited their power and then
reset the whole system and then take
everything these people own away from
them and then once we do they'll be
happy
schwab is that you
know
like some kind of economic forum for the
world
yeah like a world
economic forum of some sort of some kind
well when we were hanging out with ryan
and danny the other day we played that
video of the guy filling up the back of
his pickup truck that's what i'm
thinking about and i'm like now now you
understand bill gates but klaus schwab's
probably better klaus is like sitting
there and like he's sitting in his
lounge chair with his belly hanging out
he's like clicking youtube videos and
then he watches a guy pouring gas in the
back of a pickup truck and he's like i
must do something about that
kim do you when you think about like the
just the sheer stupidity of some humans
to destroy themselves and everyone
around them like what do you like the
plebeians in the roman times they were
like there's the elite central few that
runs society and everyone else is a
plebeian because they're too stupid to
understand at which end of the fork to
hold like how do you do you see do you
think that that's real that there's like
a small group of really hyper
intelligent humans and everyone else is
like a dumb like a follower and that we
need to live like that we need to
structure society around that obviously
yes
how do you see it
because i'm having a hard time not
seeing it like that
i think i think ian makes a good point
because i'm sure many in the audience
think that about you no but i'm not
saying that to be funny sure a lot of
people you're in this situation you're
the leader i'm the follower it's very
specific what i mean is there are a lot
of people who are like i think ian has
bad ideas you know what i mean
and so therefore we need to control you
yeah right right yeah like there are
people there the idea that there are
people you cannot let run society
because they'll fill the back of their
truck up with gasoline
i will say this there is a there is a
brilliant fulton sheen quote
we cannot allow society to be led by
people who never learned to obey it in
other words we are run by people who
never learned to follow the rules and
always saw themselves as above the law
and so what happens when they take
control they're completely lawless and
that's tyranny but everybody feels that
way about everybody so that's the
problems then who do you decide you know
exactly when you look at it just even in
our government now you've got democrats
thinking that and then you have
republicans thinking that so which one
are you going to choose yeah
unfortunately i don't think i do decide
at this point i've becoming i've become
a jaded cynic i'm i'm just all about i'm
going to go live in the woods i'm going
to get a bunch of chickens you already
did that i know i hear what you're
saying i live by my you know like
my word is your code
yeah my code i hear what you're saying
about the fact that there are a lot of
different perspectives on this but we
also have to be very careful not to fall
into the trap of relativism and still be
willing to acknowledge that there is
truth hood and falsehood and the best we
can do is try to pursue that which is
good and noble and pure and true as best
as we possibly can even if there's some
potential for us to get it wrong at
least we will have tried
i get i really don't like wealth that
wealth goes from parent to kid on death
that makes me so who should it go to
instead just disperse into nothingness
or something i don't know then why would
people want to earn wealth for their
children well you earn it for yourself
and then your children earn it for
themselves no am i on right now here i
am i'm listening to a commie and
somebody
who's like pushing for vaccine mandates
i'm pushing for vaccine mandates i'm
basically the exact opposition because
when you say my morality is for the good
of the the greater good yes then that is
basically what people that push for
vaccine mandate say they say yeah my
morality is for the greater good so but
do you believe that some moral claims
can be true and others can be false the
problem is not saying that there is good
and truth in the world and that we
should try to promote what is true the
issue is people trying to promote
falsehood as if it's true
i want to
oh i want to go deep on this well i want
to ask you a question because
everybody's posting one's in chat right
now after what he said oh i have a
question for you yeah you said uh so ian
said he doesn't like that money goes
from parent to child is that that's it
and the reason i say that is because i
see a lot of incapable kids earn a lot
of money and have a lot of power in
society but but just just i want to make
sure i get your point yeah okay so uh
imagine this scenario you have a 40 year
old man
he's got three kids and they're
middle teenagers and he's a billionaire
and uh they have a big house
they have a very very large house and
they'll live in it and then uh one day
the guy is walking downstairs and he
sees his kids making breakfast and he
goes hello there's whoa and slips and
then falls on his neck and snap his neck
cracks
should the government come and burn the
house down and kick the kids out and put
them in an orphanage no
so how do you what do those kids do
right
maybe there's like a
house an amount
okay so the government comes in takes
the house kicks the kids out and gives
them each 100 grand so like a giant tax
i don't know 90 percent taxes why do
those kids have 100 to begin with well
well what do you like so this is the
issue this is this is why we tr if
somebody is working because they want to
provide for their kids
the problem is wealth doesn't mean rich
wealth is just the the reason the the
money and resources you have so there
could be a guy who's worth a hundred
thousand dollars
his total net worth this means he's got
12 000 in savings he's got a mortgage on
his house and you know liabilities plus
assets and equals about 100 grand and he
lives in the suburbs and his kids go to
school his kid's 16 17 years old and
then he dies and the mom dies or
whatever they both had a car accident
you got to transfer what the parents had
to the kids otherwise the kids are just
homeless
so that's the way it works so it's also
interesting because ian there have been
some analyses which have suggested that
inheritance taxes make income inequality
worse because when you look at middle
class people generally their best way of
generating intergenerational wealth is
through home ownership property
ownership it's basically what they can
pass on to their children and so we've
also seen it disproportionately harming
farmers because their wealth is stored
up in their land and the crops that they
grow and i just find it interesting how
these left-wing economic policies almost
always end up going after the people who
make our food it's not necessarily
intentional but it almost always ends up
uh
resulting in food becoming more
difficult to produce or more expensive
the owners of blackrock when they die
blackrock goes to their kids like why
well their shares yeah that's publicly
traded
it could be that i'm just talking about
something that's way too ahead of its
time because we're on the money system
as long as we're using money as our
currency we're there's going to be this
probably using currency you mean no the
currency has evolved over time it used
to be shells we would trade little gems
and shells
and then we created money as a currency
type now we have electricity as a
currency type but like
the idea that money is the final form of
currency got us into this position in
the first place got to stop you there
because you're just very money is a form
of currency man they're not the same
thing
uh
okay you need a i think they're more
equitable
like electricity would make a lot you
know what do you know what like currency
is
can you define it the definition i could
look it up really quick right a trade
medium yeah so that somebody who makes
bread can trade something that holds
value as an intermediary shells are
money gems are money no no they're
currency money is a type of currency as
a trade medium what's like lightweight
cash yeah well whether you do it in a
dollar bill or you do it in a seashell
it's the same thing or electricity
but we don't we don't trade no
electricity is different that would be
like i trade you bread for the
electricity so that's the training of
goods and what currency does is it
allows for me to trade
i am i don't want your electricity i
don't think electricity is what it is
i think it's cut to the point where if
we don't have it we're screwed well ian
can i ask you
how would you correct for the double
coincidence of wants that she was just
explaining the problem of sometimes one
person who's generating wealth doesn't
necessarily have something that they can
trade directly with the other person who
has something that they want
then maybe that they just aren't able to
make the trade like let's say tim's got
a bunch of benefits that's a good system
or are you just sort of saying that
descriptively um i don't think that just
because you have a lot of money means
that you're the guy that gets to pick
who gets to trade what let me tell you
guys a story i don't think that's i
don't think that's what currency does
let me tell you guys a story this is a
story about occupy wall street okay one
day i was at occupy wall street and i
saw a woman who had a table and on that
table she had a whole bunch of socialism
books
and i heard her talking to somebody
about how money is the root of all of
our problems and to get rid of money and
i was like i'm i'm with it i'm like
alright cool i hear you i hear you i'm
you know i'm confused right so i asked
her i was like so you don't think we
should have money and she goes no we
shouldn't people should get access to
equal goods and i said okay here i have
a problem so here at occupy wall street
i go out on these marches and i live
stream them that's a real value to the
people who are protesting because then
people can hear and see and share right
it's like right yes of course and i was
like okay should i get something in
exchange for doing something of value
for the community well absolutely and i
said right
when i leave to go when people to follow
these marches and film them
when i by the time i come back
all of the food has been given away
because the people who aren't working
walk up get the food for nothing and
then by the time i'm back from doing
work there's no food left and she said
well then maybe we hold some of the food
for you you know and and i said okay i
like the idea how do we track
who you know i'm i'm asking her in all
sincerity i'm like how do we track you
know do we have like a list of people
it's like we have to have these food for
these people would it get complicated
and she goes well maybe they issue like
vouchers they'll give you like a piece
of paper that represents the work you
did or something and i went like money
hilarious and she was like no no no not
like money and i'm like but if i had a
voucher that just said it was worth some
kind of trade meat like it was worth the
work i did i could trade that with
someone else and they could turn it in
for the food it's called scrip
corporations used to do that well that's
a type of money it's a type of currency
called scrip and they would corporations
would give out script to their workers
and you can only use it at the company
yeah but if i don't want to buy from
that company store right that's the
problem and that's why we have currency
we have money that we can use as an as
you know so that i could if i don't want
tim's bananas but but he wants what i've
got bread and you've got gems to sell me
that to make jewelry or something you
know i i don't want all these things and
so we trade in money in order to get
those the downside is even the rich guy
can get a big loan and have all this
funny money that he can buy all the
stuff
because he had access to the dollars so
so the
like money what is the value of money
galactic federation uses credits
yeah but i don't think they really would
at that point if they're materializing
matter they wouldn't need that stuff you
got to watch star trek man because you
know what you're talking about
platinum i mean brown doesn't even know
what he's talking about do you even
watch star trek bro do you even space
journey
how are we going to have a conversation
on economics
gene roddenberry's work well let's table
i'm down a table this talk
i actually pulled up a few of the key
differences between money and currency i
was like this is a great question so
money can be stored uh sorry money can
be a store of value and is intangible in
nature currency cannot be a store of
value although it is always tangible in
nature so tangibility money refers to
actual value of goods or services that's
traded for currency is just a medium
that we keep in our pockets to increase
our purchasing power and to make
day-to-day payments in our lives that
that sounds like bs because that makes
sense
i don't see how that makes sense i don't
understand what money is yeah there's
cash then there's there's digital dot
dots ones and zeros in a bank ledger
somewhere those are different okay so
maybe that's what they're saying yeah so
money is what you have in your bank
account right currency is what i what i
have in my wallet right okay so that's a
dollar i don't know that's that's
interesting yeah because they're also
saying that money has intrinsic value
which you could easily argue that fed
money does not happen
right so that makes sense actually
because
all the money that it was printed wasn't
really printed by the fed they just put
it into their ledger right but they're
just adding money they're not adding
currency into the market oh there's
there i don't i don't believe there will
ever be a circumstance in which we will
not have money yeah i don't know
we have to have money i don't think that
there's any way like you said because if
you are going out and videoing something
how can somebody trade that with you
there's uh
you know first we have the the laws of
thermodynamics right
so even when they're conceptualizing a
show like star trek the next generation
they try there's a real there's really
interesting contradictions in the
contradictions in the show where in some
instances they're like we've we don't
use money anymore because we have
replicators but they have beachfront
they have late they have riverfront
property or bay front property in san
francisco like how do you uh how do you
distribute wealth or or allocate
resources
so
i don't know how that would make sense
living in a star trek style future with
no money but someone gets to live on the
bay no there's value there and people
will strive and say how do i do
something to earn more is it appointed
to you well communists have tried
arguing star trek is communist and they
explain this is one of the reasons why
the problem is in the actual show they
couldn't overcome logical fallacies or
logical plot conundrums without
explaining the use of money why would
there be a need for exploration if you
could replicate everything ah the
replicators can't make certain complex
substances so you have to go and find
them and get them otherwise it would be
a show about a bunch of gods flying
around doing whatever they wanted
there'd be no constraints so within the
within the laws of physics when we try
conceptualizing a science fiction show
we're like there's there has to be money
otherwise they're just teleporting gods
who can do whatever they want because
they're constrained by nothing well yeah
and also even if it were the case that
we ended up in some kind of
post-scarcity landscape the reality is
it's really an incoherent idea because
your time will always be scarce
there's always going to be an
opportunity cost to everything you do
post scarcity isn't even like i said
it's not a coherent concept in this
world i i believe your your time is the
most your most valuable resource way
more than any amount of money you could
be given on birth so like what you do
with your life is is the value
and also like what am i going to get for
what i give maybe that's a archaic
concept like why do you why do people
feel like they need something in return
for giving just if they have enough
survival if you have enough to survive
and to thrive then sustainability why
must we profit you know for your
children yeah if you have enough to
sustain and your children have enough to
sustain them why do you need to rip
people off and rip people off or why do
you need to get things for the things
it's just a different i get what he's
saying and i think that there may be is
a solution to it where it's like there's
a cap where you've had okay so it
doesn't hurt the farmers and it doesn't
hurt even the millionaires it's like
there's a cap and then the rest of that
has to do
i i absolutely disagree why is there a
system of profit um well some people are
good at things and some people aren't
yeah but some people are born into it
right that is true right some people are
good things in some cases that's true
but some people are getting things not
because they're good at something right
but that's that's that's that's like an
issue but if so if you have a system
where some dude is like i've figured out
a way to create energy that's extremely
effective you know and efficient
and then we say but we're going to put a
limit on how much you can actually grow
your business that's a bad thing well no
no john rockefeller did that exact thing
he figured out how to transport oil with
with pipelines and then they had to
break up his company because it was too
powerful uh standard oil
so i'm saying like
stopping monopolies is different from
telling the little guy he can't have 30
or more employees you know actually
sounds the same
i don't think so yeah i mean it's
exactly the same thing if you're going
to break up a monopoly you are saying to
that business owner you cannot have x y
thing no matter how good you are at
getting that thing but i'm talking about
scale i'm not talking about like
principle yeah hard law i'm saying that
like censorship for instance censorship
is actually a good thing depending on
the context if someone's posting child
abuse on websites we certainly want
censors to like get rid of that find
those people and arrest them we don't
want our political opinions to be
censored that's you know but then
there's a challenge in what constitutes
a political opinion so you have morality
issues if there's one company that
controls all communications and they're
censoring their political rivals or it's
a cabal in silicon valley we got a very
serious problem if it's like one small
website who is having their domains
seized by big
companies so we want to protect the
smaller you know a guy so
my point is
yes in certain circumstances anti-trust
makes sense but the idea someone is
allowed to earn more money they're not
ripping somebody off they're allowed to
expand their business we just don't want
them to control all of the market
you know what i mean
that's what's going to be sure
yeah so let's let's let's talk about uh
this this store we got from cnbc
inflation rose 7.9 percent in february
as food and energy costs push prices to
the highest in more than 40 years every
single month it's good every week same
headlines
same headline they're like the new
numbers have come out and it's worse
than it's been in four decades and i'm
like i feel like i just saw the january
numbers right and that was seven and 7.5
and now it's 7.9 in february so let's
talk about what this means for you guys
ian was just discussing money and
currency and there's some interesting
questions to have here i don't care
about the u.s dollar in terms of what
that means for you because we got other
numbers to deal with what i care about
is how many hours do you have to work to
eat a meal to to live to have health
care and this is the big problem i have
with the left when they're like 15
minimum wage and i'm like
the number
and the piece of paper or the digital
currency does not change that you will
have to work a set amount of hours to
earn certain resources
if it's it's simple if everyone in the
country is getting paid 15 bucks an hour
to make a widget the cost of widgets
goes up with the cost of labor so
changing the number does not change the
amount of time taken from the person to
produce the object
so my my thing is when it comes to
better standards of living we need it's
a supply and demand issue with labor
versus uh
supply demand of demand for labor versus
supply of labor and it's what people are
willing to work for right now people are
not willing to work for that much but
the fact remains
if if it's by government force or by
unionization
if every single person says you know
what the government won't raise our
wages then we're all going to demand it
you will still get inflation and you
will still work the exact same amount of
hours for the exact same resources but
this was the argument
against abolishing slavery
i mean if you well because if you want
really cheap good i mean if you're
saying that well you can't raise wages
because if you raise wages then that's
going to raise the cost of goods
i'm saying that
money represents
time and value time and labor time and
labor won't change by mandate
so
what you'll get is there's a few
interesting things the minimum wage will
allow people to buy computers
for for uh for less less time of their
lives
so we get our computers made by you know
like sweatshop and slave labor in a
foreign country and if a computer costs
500
and you get 500 per week from your job
if we give you a 20 raise it'll take you
20 less time to buy that product because
the product is imported from a com from
a country that uses slave labor but if
you're buying american made goods and
their wages go up the same as yours you
now have to pay the same amount of time
for that for their amount of time
right so basically you're saying then
so then what is your solution
to keep wages low
what do you mean for certain groups of
people in order to keep the goods low
that's not that's not a principle or a
moral position that's a fact
it's just it's just a mathematical fact
changing the representation of time and
labor doesn't change time and labor
that's the so if someone comes out and
says but let's put it this way let's use
arbitrary uh gaff tape for every hour
you work you get one gaff tape oh my if
we say well i demand two gaff tape it's
like okay but you still have to work for
for an hour and these items just
represent that hour it doesn't matter
how many of them you have what matters
is what someone is willing to pay in
terms of their time for your time
so
money as a number is
mostly arbitrary it's not entirely and
i'll tell you so i'll tell you when it
comes to inflation what happens is if
you work for one hour and you're given
money to represent that one hour of
labor you can now exchange it for the
equivalent value of one hour of someone
else's labor with inflation your time is
being stripped away so now you worked
for an hour and it's the equivalent to a
half an hour that's inflation
the the the actual number of the
currency this is completely missed by
money on the left and they argue for
minimum wage
if we eliminated currency from the from
the from the from the question
you'd be saying to someone okay
you work for one hour at my restaurant
and you'll be able to buy a meal okay
money is irrelevant whether the meal
costs five dollars or ten dollars one
hour gets you one meal
if you tell if you have two guys and one
guy makes the meal and one guy sources
the food they're both still going to
have to work one hour of their life to
exchange the meal to give the food to
the guy to make the meal so they could
both enjoy it you change their minimum
wage and now ten dollars represents
their one hour they're still asking for
an hour of each other's time
so
the solution to minimum wage issues is
supply and demand if but but again it's
the system is never going to change this
will always be the case even if it's
done through capitalism or if it's done
through government command economies the
only thing that you'll get is ebbs and
flows
so one of the things i think is good
about a minimum wage increase is that
imported goods that we get from slaves
will be easier to acquire for people
working minimum wage
americans don't want to admit the
reality of their slave-made goods but
that's the reality so if a slave is
going to work for one hour to make you
know 50 shirts in the united states if
we give you a minimum wage increase that
won't be a wage increase for the slave
who's getting paid garbage or not
getting paid at all americans love their
foreign products they absolutely do made
in china across the board
if we were to increase the wage of the
sweatshop worker
same as you
you would not see you might see a lag in
goods that already exist coming through
and so that's one benefit of raising
minimum wages
so if a shirt is made and then the
person gets paid to make it and they go
and buy food and then 30 days later the
shirt arrives the cost of that shirt is
still say five bucks
however in the past week you got a
dollar raise and you made six bucks this
week so you can buy the five dollar
shirt and have a dollar left over it
feels good
however
now that they've given a raise to the
other guy within a week's time the
shirt's now six dollars so raising the
minimum wage is a temporary it's a ponzi
scheme the whole the whole system is a
big ponzi scheme but you know there you
go it buys about eight months the people
love those eight months of of currency
raise because you can get 20 more stuff
well look what happened at the beginning
of the pandemic our government engaged
in the largest transfer of wealth that
has occurred in all of human history
they printed about 2.2 trillion about
450 billion of that went to the fed to
leverage out 4.5 trillion in loans and
the way the wealth is redistribute
redistributed in a very insidious way is
the people who get the money first in
loans before the inflation really hits
are the ones who benefit and that comes
off the back of everyone else who now
has more difficulty affording things and
who have lost the value of their savings
because that money was printed devaluing
the currency or because it was flooded
into the marketplace devaluing the
currency the people that get first
access to the money yes that's really
disturbing exactly yeah it's a
redistribution of wealth from people who
access the money first or two people who
access the money first from everybody
else but that was because they actually
added money into the system that didn't
exist prior to that point yeah so it
would be different if you're raising
minimum wage and a corporate a corporate
boss was told you have to raise the wage
to 15 an hour but you have to do it out
of the resources you currently have
you're not getting more from me i'm not
going to print money and give it to you
but it i mean it affects so for example
you have inflation in certain sectors
just depending on how the wealth is
redistributed
as opposed to new money being created so
for example when the federal government
started guaranteeing student loans
colleges started raising their prices
which was an inflation within that
particular field even though new money
wasn't actually created so you'd have to
actually stop greedy inflation because
there's really no more demand it's not a
supply or demand issue and you're
talking about things like college
education necessarily
yeah i know i hear you i mean i would
agree with things that are not tangible
when you're looking at college education
there's certainly yeah i mean it's it's
greed but we also know based on all the
research according to the national
bureau for economic research i should
say
colleges are going to respond to those
kinds of subsidies by raising the prices
i think what we have to do is just shift
the incentives and consider the
incentives before implementing any kind
of policy because
the idea behind guaranteeing student
loans was more people will be able to go
to college it was a very nice idea but
they didn't actually think through the
incentives that was creating for the
colleges and it ended up making college
less accessible for everybody in the
long run that's why you have to do it as
a two-step process so not only do you
offer an affordable education to
somebody in a way by giving them some
sort of access to a loan or
or even just tuition free tuition but
you then would have to have the second
step being that you you do the control
on the university itself yeah i think
there's an argument to be made i think
to look into a specific policy
prescription there but i think we just
you know
get rid of universities you always say
that right we need education do you like
the house you live in because you need
an architect to build it do you like the
roads you drive on do you like the
doctors you guys this house wasn't built
by an architect either well somebody had
to actually then it's not structurally
sound and is it gonna collapse on me
this house was actually built by a bunch
of local dudes but either way some
architecture over time had
somebody had to check it to make sure
that it was structurally sound and that
me that was an educated person who
understood architecture in order to
ensure that the beams are in the right
spot that you have support beams where
they need to be which of course it's
true no i mean what about a skyscraper
so you just want to let anybody just go
and build a skyscraper without an
education and know how to do it do you
need a certification to build a
skyscraper
it sure helps i mean look like i'm not
going to go to just any random yahoo
architecture for my doctors for example
so architecture is art and engineering
is the actual structure right so an
architect will like draw a pretty
picture of a building with like cool
like arches and the engineer has to
figure out how to distribute weight and
do things like that for this house
specifically this this is true story i
it's it's it was built um by a bunch of
local guys who just knew uh
basic carpentry and and construction and
so they all understood the basic weight
every beam of wood has like a you know
uh what what what's the right word um
how much weight it can withstand so they
have like two beams here two beams there
and they're like okay these beams can
hold this weight so we can build up to
this side because the total weight
pressed
it's not it's not
it's not coming from university they
learn these things so we've built stuff
on our own we're having skate ramps
built and it's just guys who know how to
put nails in wood and know the general
capacity of certain wood
they just they you learn these things
over time you can learn those things but
how do you control the quality of that
education that somebody learned so
somebody could come knocking on my door
like a snake oil salesman and be like
hey guess what kim i could build you a
house in your backyard i know how to do
it i learned all of it where did you
learn it online i watched youtube videos
okay fine but how do i prove your work
right well somebody would have to have
trusted him to start an apprenticeship
but here's the thing i mean so the
person gets a job as an apprentice when
they're young working for that's no
different than a university that's what
a university is apprenticeship just
online
one pays you and you pay the other but a
lot of times you can't find an
apprentice that will take you on because
it's nepotist you know the nepotism or
it's who you know or they're paid off by
somebody it's essentially a university i
mean that's a university is just that's
not an argument for the for the for the
for the situation at hand that's just an
argument for potent maybe there's crime
or maybe there's social problems if the
issue is
you're going to tell someone to go spend
tens of thousand dollars to go to
university so they can learn something
and be in a classroom versus someone can
get paid to work even if you're just
getting coffee to start for the first
month and actually watch something
happening in real time university is
detrimental
so well first of all i don't think you
should have to pay tens of thousands of
dollars for university so it should be
something that is well who pays for it
well i don't think
knowledge shouldn't be so expensive i
mean you certainly would want your
professors
and the
to to be able to live and feed their
families and have a nice life so that
they're incentivized to become
professors
but it doesn't need to be
to the level where it's at where these
universities are getting these you know
they have these massive
uh accounts worth billions and billions
of dollars i mean it's just outrageous
but so you know you'd have to find this
so with this whole idea of going to a
society and just eliminating university
well i'm not actually calling for
eliminating universities you just did
that was me being hyperbolic for i
thought those failures say it every time
i talk i don't think you're really
like
you don't like university i think people
shouldn't go to them but i think in
terms of like research at universities
and grants are fine for certain jobs
like um you want to be a doctor i
understand why we make people go to
school to be a doctor and get a
certification there but for the most
part universities should be like
an aside you know well so maybe they've
expanded and maybe you don't maybe you
don't agree with all of the
all of the uh topics that they teach
i'll tell you this
if someone tries to get a job from me
and they have
college on their resume it's a net
negative outright out of the gate but
that's just because you have bias but
that's just you
you absolutely yeah yeah quite literally
and it's because in my experience i have
already hired many people who have spent
too much time at institutionalized
learning facilities and have not enough
real world experience they can't
understand how to make things function
properly so for me personally i'm like
if you've spent this much of your life
in school
you probably
you know i think that's a net negative
however portfolio is the most important
thing you come to me and say i went to
college i'll say sure whatever show me
your portfolio you can't do that i'm not
interested
but my issue is you know i've spent a
lot of time around people who have
chosen to start working from a young age
worked side jobs throughout high school
and then decided to get into an industry
outside of high school and then a lot of
people who went to college and didn't
know what they're going to college for
but they were told to by their parents
and that's what everyone was told to do
racked up a bunch of debt and now i have
no idea what they're doing their lives
that are miserable paying off debt
working crappy jobs
right so the debt part is the issue it's
not really the actual experience of
going to college because you can't
expect every 18 year old to know what
they want to do with their lives at the
time that they're 18. i disagree i think
that's a huge social problem we have i
knew what i wanted to do for the most
part but that was you so again it's you
know there's a lot of people that
they're still finding themselves and
they shouldn't be at 18 because you're
an adult at 18. and so for so this is
one of the problems we have as a country
when i was a little kid i was playing
music i was skateboarding i was
rollerblading and i was programming
websites and video games on the computer
and i was reading the news when i was
like 10 years old i'm on compuserve and
aol and i'm reading articles and i'm
doing it and somehow managed to here i
am you know not 36. a bunch of my
friends were doing literally nothing you
know my i was homeschooled from the time
i was born until i started preschool
until i started kindergarten a bunch of
my friends sat around doing nothing but
watching tv just mindless nonsense by
the time they're 18 they're like i don't
know what i'm doing and i was like i've
written several songs i've recorded and
published them i've made several
websites i've done a bunch of odd jobs
and then people were like go to college
i was like what for
i already i'm already working i'm
already getting experience in all this
stuff and i'm watching people go to
college being completely clueless the
problem is we as a society have been
telling our kids to do nothing and say
just go to school just go to school
we've put them in institutionalized
learning facilities that don't teach
them anything school sucks you know
every every kid thinks it every kid says
it so we're taking kids and saying for
the for 22 years of your life you're
going somewhere you hate now you're 22.
you're out of college i expect you to
have skills that's going to be valuable
to society and they don't it's not
surprising
but a lot of them do a lot of them do i
think that's a relative argument i think
if you took a kid who grew up and worked
on his dad's farm or in his dad's
smithing shop or smelting you know work
smelling or watched his dad weld and
then he grew up and went to high school
and learned basic math and stuff and
working at the family business you take
that person at 18 compared to an 18 year
old who did none of those things the 18
year old fresh out of high school who
worked for his dad's job is going to
tell you about accounting finance
banking he's going to explain to you
what time the workers come in he's going
to know about the labor laws and that
other kids going to be like i have no
idea what any of that is and you expect
the kid who did nothing but go to an
institutionalized learning facility to
know what they want to do with their
life the kid who was welding when he was
13 is going to be like i once made this
really cool structure with my dad
they're gonna have that memory they're
gonna have the experience at the very
least they're gonna have real world work
experience and connections in their
community i think school is one of the
biggest detriments to human civilization
i think that i understand parents can't
be there explaining math and history to
all these kids but now you take a look
at what's going on with like florida
don't say gay you take a look at what's
going on with teachers refusing to let
parents know what they're teaching their
kids and then teaching these kids a lot
of complete wacky activist nonsense i'm
like it's just gotten worse from the
get-go we used to be a civilization of
apprentices the kids would watch the
parents work i had not not only was i
homeschooled but my mom opened a coffee
house and i got to watch how the
business worked so i'm in sixth grade
and i'm i'm earning money and so i've
got money i've got responsibility i
bought my own game boy and my own
pokemon red
that was that was for me i guess in this
civilization i was lucky to have all
those things you were i wish that my
parents had a business i always wished
that growing up and that's what we need
to do
but the thing is is it you know i agree
with you that society definitely pushes
education way too hard and that they
devalue
the apprenticeship sort of track for
kids and i do agree that they absolutely
allow kids to just kind of go through
and not know what they're wanting to do
and just continue on that aimless path
but you know just even looking in you
sharing your experience my me sharing
mine anecdotally my dad on his side of
the family my grandfather was a farmer
he was the son of a farmer that
immigrated here from denmark then ran
the farm my grandfather hated the farm
he became a teamster he was a trucker he
supported all seven kids being a truck
driver my grandmother was a secretary at
a newspaper
all seven of my dad's siblings of the
seven kids my dad was the only one who
went to college everybody else in my
family blew collar workers they all
worked in factories they were dry
cleaners they were landscapers they were
working to the bone every day back
breaking work my dad went to college got
a computer programming degree was able
to then get a really good job
out of the seven kids we absolutely had
more money than the others there's no
doubt about that how old was your dad
like when was he born 47.
so my theory on this is that your dad
likely went to college because he liked
computers and he was passionate about
something see back then our society
didn't tell people college was mandatory
right so your dad you know so if you're
if you're in this age you know in the in
the 60s and 70s
people were able to get a high school
diploma and then support their family a
family of five just a high school
diploma was normal so why go to college
at all unless you really wanted to
because you were passionate about it so
i'd argue your dad made more money
because of his passion not because he
went to college well because the job he
got commanded more money so he was able
to get a job of a higher wage that put
us into upper middle class versus my
family which was blue collar middle
class you know you know what i love
jimmy john's sandwiches is it difficult
to make sandwiches
no do you need a degree to learn how to
make a sandwich absolutely not but jimmy
john is a rich dude because he made a
lot of sandwiches right so
the college argument for wealth me to me
makes absolutely no sense you could you
could be the best dang chimney sweep in
the country and be a millionaire but
that's like one but that's a few so you
have an entire group of let's say
lawyers right as a whole on average they
make way more money than an entire group
of sandwich makers so you've got yes the
jimmy john who happens to be and i know
jimmy john actually who happens to be a
big fan
we ordered jimmy john every day this
week because of my birthday weekend i
love jimmy john's also but i you know i
used to live in champaign illinois i did
radio really at the time yeah i've been
through the area quite a bit yeah we put
them on the panini grill and get them oh
man oh really i've never tried that oh
that's good yeah i mean they are good
damn good sandwiches right yes lawyers
make more than sandwich makers but on
average right no matter what job you
choose you can be rich if you're
passionate and driven also sandwich
makers are much more popular
that's true too they're way more liked
right there's no doubt about that but
you know i look at my mom's side of the
family for example and they're all
vietnamese immigrants and what do you
think vietnamese immigrants do when they
come here to america i'll give you one
guess
nobody wants to be there no nobody wants
to i want to say something but i'm not
going to say it on tv all right you said
nail salons right so they do nail salons
so everybody in my family on my mom's
side and they work and they scrub feet
literally for a living
it is it's very hard work and they do it
so that they would put my generation
through college and what do they tell
all of us kids they say you're going to
go to college and you're going to be
engineer you're going to be doctor
you're going to be a lawyer right and
that's it and that was the only choices
we had we had like three choices and
that's all you could be and it was they
were scrubbing feet in order to put us
into college in order to get those jobs
because on average now my generation
which is you know now we're in our 30s
and 40s we on average make more money
than my mom's generation now that being
said my aunt
is a very wealthy nail salon owner who
owns a ton of nail salons in the beverly
hills area so she owned five nails and
she does all the celebrity nails she's
been the big hot shot nail salon owner
in beverly hills since 1988 makes the
most money out of everybody there's no
doubt about that but collectively as a
whole my generation makes more money
than my mom's generation
on average so there was the one that got
lucky but she has to support the rest
my generation none of us have to support
each other because we all make enough
money to support ourselves i mean why i
don't think it's luck at all you know
one one it was hard work for sure but it
was also luck because a lot of other
people work very very hard and i don't
want to discount the fact that somebody
works very very hard but just never got
the break in life to make a bunch of
money i think it's the break i think
it's you know the the saying is chance
favors the prepared
some people are prepared to make
sacrifices or take chances and others
aren't but sometimes your chance and and
the success like you were born here in
america so you had the opportunity to
have a lot of success in america but if
you were an immigrant coming in from
like el salvador and you've got to
literally walk your rear end all the way
across a continent to get yourself into
america that was a lot of hard work and
then you get here and maybe you're only
living in a two-bedroom apartment but to
you that's rich compared to where you
could have lived in a two-bedroom
apartment no i'm saying to that person
if that person lived in a two-bedroom
apartment here that's to them wealth
they've made it right yeah compared to
you is not yeah it was but right
but to this guy even i mean this guy was
living in a shack and on dirt in el
salvador or something so everybody's
wealth is relative to where they came
from
you know and so i mean i know guys that
started off with millions and then they
made billions yeah and to them that was
donald trump you start off with a
million dollars
of a million dollars that's a problem
to sweden and seeing the bad
neighborhoods in sweden and i was like
this is so nice
like the houses like the apartments for
like the poor people were just like
the wealthy area of chicago and i told
them that and they were just like yeah
i'm like chicago's bad man this
really fast you had to go to sweden to
figure that out let's let's go to super
chats though and uh you know we'll have
more on this guy i think it's i love the
conversation by the way but we'll go to
super chats now because we want to make
sure we get as many as possible smash
the like button subscribe to the channel
share the share with your friends go to
timcast.com become a member we're going
to have a special members only segment
up at 11 p.m on the website you don't
want to miss it let's read more from you
guys we got tear 728 says the judge
looked like a complete clown after the
sentencing he doubled down in his lies
the judge did and proceeded to inflame
racial tensions further after years of
court wasted resources five felonies
perjury on the stand and hours for hours
et cetera
you mean a jesse looked like a complete
clown after sentencing the judge it says
the judge but doesn't i don't think the
judge was the one yelling
all right
you know maybe this is a this is a
pro-jesse tweet it's a
uh super chat just saying cristiano says
kim thanks for keeping it real over
there at rising ryan and robbie are cool
and all but you're the one bringing the
fire
i do have to say i think you were the
perfect person for them to have uh have
hired for rising they haven't
technically hired me oh well then
they're nuts
but when i when i heard that they they
were like they were having you come on
rising i was like smartest decision they
could have made oh thank you yeah ryan's
great that guy's awesome yeah
your friends
he seems real stable
ryan yeah yeah he's got a real like
soothing presence he's very cool yeah
today you know i just met him for the
first time today oh wow yeah in person
never met him and he's real quiet
raymond g stanley jr says kim how do you
feel about working with savvy
suave suave oh good i mean i like i love
both of them they're both great i like
ryan and robbie we're all friends
all right
that's it
all right i don't see them much i'm in
la you know and they're here in d.c
and so i like i said i've met robbie one
time when he came to la and i've i just
met ryan for the first time today so
w falcon says the trifecta tim kim and
shim
i know she could have made it kim cast
but she
yeah why did we do that alpha freedom
fighter says tim today is my son's fifth
birthday can you shout him out happy
birthday lincoln hennessey oh cute
nice good name sarah says happy belated
birthday i hope this gets you a couple
of nice extra well done steaks at your
favorite and your favorite bottle of
ketchup yeah i love it
you know it's we call it the trump you
know you get it nice and seared and
cooked all the way through
yeah brown and tough we got to get some
sloppy gigantic ketchup without the high
fructose i can't do the high fructose
it's gross we should make our own oh we
should grow our own tomatoes and make
our own easily done yeah
all right let's grab some more soup
stephen says hey tim you're going to go
see sonnet hedgehog 2 next month you
know it i haven't seen the batman yet
maybe i should go see that yeah i hear
it's good i'm waiting for it to come out
on hbo max batman
it's long it's three hours too much yeah
man
all right they've raised the prices of
movies so much
well how much are they now well and now
i think amc didn't they which one
announced that they're going to be did
they announce that they're going to be
doing it based on the popularity of the
movie really i don't like that yes
that's terrible just wait until it comes
out at home
big stupid stock it's just it's
fascinating how that's going to affect
box office numbers too because we were
talking earlier about like economics and
incentives and the more expensive the
movie becomes
as it gets more popular the fewer people
are going to want to pay the money to go
see it maybe they'll start off cheap and
then as the week you want to go see it
early before it starts getting expensive
it's like an ipo dude you're a scalper
and if you think a movie's gonna be
really popular you buy up a bunch of
tickets before it gets popular and then
you start selling them outside the
theater it's like an ipo though you know
they're basically saying like you know
resident evil is going to be starting at
10 bucks because we don't think anyone's
gonna want to see it and then people are
like yeah i'll do ten bucks see it i
think i'll see it you know i'll buy a
thousand of those tickets it's
interesting though because it'll even it
out though if every i'm fascinated to
see how that turns out because if each
film doesn't cost the same amount people
are going to make their decision to see
a film based on the price which is not
something we've really seen before with
major motion pictures see how it goes
yeah
all right
chris blank production says who wants to
place bets that simulat will write a
book about being innocent in prison
after all of this well he's not going to
present with jill if i did it
a true story you know be really funny if
like jesse really was innocent i know
the funniest thing ever dude what a what
a great twilight zone episode that would
be what a twist oh we should we should
make that we should we should just do it
come on like who wants to produce crazy
let's hire him he's an actor when he
gets out of jail be like look you're
probably never going to work again we
can give you one more opportunity we
give you one more opportunity to act on
this for us we're going to tell your
story yeah
oh my gosh we offered to tell a story if
i didn't
i was saying before we should do the
justice millette short short film
you know we can go to chicago and we can
film it go to nbc that would be amazing
you know building right there and all
right well who which one of you is going
to be jesse yeah oh no we're going to
show you this
and you're the actor that's true
actually
all right all right all right
kenny says smilet should be charged for
his uh male crime that's true too what
was that a letter was sent to the studio
before this happened
you know insulting him and calling him a
slur or something
and i it's been a while since i read it
but i'm pretty sure they said that he
said it to himself i don't know if
that's true though but i think that's
believable isn't it yeah and then when
no one when no one believed it and took
action he escalated was like okay fine
yeah so
jason says in some states you can
request a firing squad as the means to
carry a death sentence even the accused
can request it i thought i think in utah
you can request a firing squad
firing squad
i think the death penalty is wrong so
you know whatever
what would you guys pick if you had to
pick
firing squad if i had to choose yeah i
think firing squad
would you really though i guess so i
mean if i hadn't drawn and quartered oh
wow yeah that's wild is that what the
horses yeah oh what about the other
quartered because they cut you into four
pieces yeah that's great what about
carbon monoxide poisoning isn't that
peaceful
yeah i don't think they admitted
that way though why why don't they yeah
that's right it's very humane you know
yeah i think the death penalty is wrong
and we should not have it anyway because
uh you know it's too late you already
said it media matters is going to clip
it thank
thinks the death penalty should be
administered by carbon monoxide
well
i didn't say
no honestly i think i think we should be
way more humane if we are if there's
going to be a system doing it i just
think it's wrong so
anyway let's read more of these super
chats nathan coxy says the four horsemen
in revelation first horse given crown
and bow look at root words in greek and
latin they are corona and toxin second
horse causes war third horse brings
famine and the fourth
brings death to a third of the people
second seal has been opened i looked at
yeah
i just i am v i am extremely skeptical
of any claim that we are living through
revelation yeah but i will say that the
translations check out the greek is a
poisoned bow talks on not toxin talks on
t-o-x-o-n and the latin for crown of
course obviously is corona here here's
the point whether this is the end of the
world your world is going to end someday
everybody dies get ready with god yeah
the whole end of the world thing is like
a trope that throughout history people
are like oh
yeah the end is near ah you know
everybody hurts sometimes
sometimes sometimes everybody cries yeah
sometimes
i saw i remember i was when i moved to
la the first time there was a billboard
and it was like the end of the world is
coming and it was like some guy had
bought a bunch of billboards claiming
the world was going to end in like 2011
or whatever and then i remember like
the world didn't end you know right yeah
i wonder what happened all those people
in their money why y2k is that like yeah
oh my goodness
we're way overdue for y2k i think that
means it's coming soon yes yeah the end
is near yeah i'm just kidding
captain forehead says dave smith quote
if you want to know who america who
america's next enemy is look at who we
are funding right now yeah
great quote on point smart guy
we need to roll back the state we're
spying on all of our own citizens
well my favorite headline of all time is
cia armed rebels turn against fbi armed
rebels
amazing that's a real headline oh it's
so sad incredible sandwich says lava bit
was an encrypted email provider that
chose to shut down instead of handing
records over to authorities now that is
admirable good for them absolutely
that's amazing is that by the way is
that like how the cia and fbi have their
like friendly competition like that's
their annual softball game is they each
arm a group of rebels and send them to
war with each other it's like firemen
versus the better
says alex jones just posted that
pentagon warns putin may start a nuclear
war on rumble i wonder if it will turn
true like 90 of anything he says
i don't know if everything he says or
that much turns out to be true that's a
very high number the reason why there's
a bit about alex jones being right is
that he often says things that seem up
seem crazy and then it turns out he's
right
so uh you know he predicted back in
october war in february right and uh
he he talked to me a bit about how he
knew it and he said in the full show he
explains exactly how he knows it he has
sources there were certain
high level individuals making statements
and uh people clipped it but they didn't
post the full explanation
so people are like he was right again
it's like well listen to what he said he
had like sources and public sources you
know i didn't want to say that the most
hyperbolic things trump said about the
biden administration have completely
come true seven eight nine dollar gas
yeah it's totally
remember when i told you this was a
president who couldn't disappoint me
yeah is that correct
there you go
all right nonpartisan media says tim you
need to red pill ian that or start
looking into his background and see if
he's working for the deep state seems to
be pushing establishment lines more than
ever tonight lol i'm controlled
opposition dude ian are you a cop
no you have to tell me if you're a cop
that's entrance that's entrapment dude
i'm not lying right now
no come on you know ian's
he's an alien this is a lie
this is a lie what i'm saying right now
this is a lie yes
this sentence is a lie
all right seymour says trump on nalc or
mr beast on jre um mr beast on jre i
haven't listened to either of them
though yeah
but i think with trump on nelk
you know at this point i don't know if
trump's going to reveal anything we
don't already know
honestly because he just says things and
he goes he does he talks a lot he posts
a lot but i think the important things
you'd want to hear from trump right now
about the future he's he obviously isn't
going to be talking about for obvious
reasons mr beast on jre i'm interested
to see that you know uh interesting guy
it was great they're both good they're
both really good so i don't i don't know
why you you put they're very different
one's political and one's not
i like mr beast i never knew much about
him and then i'm like oh some young
upstart and now he's got like 77 million
subscribers
it was some huge number like that yeah
just gives money to people yeah that's
amazing makes money and then gives
people like that
yep get rich off giving money away
that's kind of cool
all right let's grab some more
let's see 91.6 million subscribers
number one on youtube
woody says the retroactive crime comment
made me comment how can we fight back
against the atf recently changes were
made to form one suppressors i bought a
solvent trap to make one legally now
they're considered unregistered
suppressors meaning i would be a felon
this is wrong wow yup that's what ian
was saying remember you were like the
dictator could just change the law yeah
i don't know
abolish the atf not cool
you to abolish things
biden's been talking about doing some
executive order for i'm really tired of
these executive orders by the way what
what went wrong is this george bush
started abusing it and then
ever since do you remember kim i feel
like he did start uh but it's just
escalated each presidency has used more
and more and more
yeah but i'm not 100 certain on who if
it was bush or obama obama went hard on
executive yes
it might have been obama because he was
so opposed you know they who was
mcconnell that said i'm gonna do
everything i can to stop every single
thing that this guy tries to do i
remember bush using the war on terror as
an excuse to do all sorts of extra
congressional action it was really
disturbing yeah that's what i remember
and like it's a trend that's gotta be
curved so this now granted my source
here is cnn so like let's be really
careful with this but apparently um
eisenhower had
far more uh in terms of like executive
orders than did bush obama or trump it
seems as if it was actually decreasing
for a number of years and then went up
with trump but this is cnn all right so
let's be careful check wikipedia yeah
yeah yeah
shinobi strong side says please have ian
look up jacque fresco and his larry king
interview yeah he did um jacques was uh
building this like utopian world did you
guys ever
yeah the circular cyber cities or
whatever yeah and it was without money i
think that's why he brought that up
interesting i know he did a larry king
interview though thanks
yeah check it out
but that was like the zeitgeist movement
talked a lot about jacque fresco yeah
and when i watched jacques in the uh
2006 and five i thought he was a
crackpot it was too early in my life to
really appreciate what he was doing i
thought this guy's got a dream that's
never going to happen
it was really sad and now i'm like i
should have given that guy more more
credence and kind of supported him i
think
this is fast by the way i'm looking
through a bunch of different charts from
different sources so we're not stuck
with cnn
a lot of them measure it differently but
most of them seem to have executive
orders peak unsurprisingly with fdr
interesting wartime stuff right that
would make some sense i suppose
martin buckley says does kim get
attacked for her segments by colleagues
she's like tucker having a platform on
cnn
i would say it's like tucker having a
platform on fox news have you listened
to hannity yeah
i mean do you agree you run against the
grain at hell
i would i mean uh you know i don't know
sure i mean i don't know if there's like
really a grain
but i mean i i would say that whatever
anybody's any beef that we have about my
segments you see on air so
there's been some that's cool yeah but
nothing off air nice
all right
xerocipher says for ian can i build a
good table for you 100 bucks i know a
guy that makes amazing tables that are
like works of art and sells them for 25k
how can you say he needs to sell for
what i do
or how can you quantify his skill the
market has to decide
uh yeah you can give me a table was that
the question i think he was like making
a hypothetical um give me the table dude
i i didn't really get the question it
was i got kind of confused with the
amount of words in that thing
he's asking he says that the value of
his friend's skill is such that he's
able to sell a product that's worth
twenty five thousand dollars whereas if
he were to make you a table it would be
worth one hundred dollars well it
depends on if i need a table or not well
it depends on the value of what of the
work right of the worksmanship yeah i
mean what if you put stuff on your table
and it falls down exactly look at this
table it's a great table this table is
expensive expensive table supply and
demand i think that people think just
because they're good at something they
deserve money for it as a big problem
because if there's no demand for your
work then why would they not because
this guy's never watched the dark knight
if there's no demand for your labor then
you're not going to get paid even if
you're the best on earth at it yeah what
people that do things and they just
assume they're they're
they're owed something for it if there's
no demand for your labor yeah then yeah
that whole money economy thing where
like i'm gonna go sit in a room and
stare at a wall for an hour and get paid
nine months
yeah
come on i like the line in the dark
knight great movie full of good quotes
when joker's like and simple we kill the
batman and they're like if it's so
simple why haven't you done it and he's
like my mom always said if you're good
at something don't do it for free that's
right that was so good love it i love
the i'm gonna make this pencil disappear
what a great great movie there's a lot
of plot holes in it like it's kind of
dejected as a film but it's one of my
favorite films you know weird jumping
points like whatever i need to watch
that movie but oh man i got to tell you
one of the best lines that seriously the
writing for the joker in the dark knight
when he's talking to harvey dent
wow
you know that scene where he's in the
hospital check it out
and i turned it on itself he's got he's
like if i were to tell the media that
like a gang banger will get shot or a
truckload of soldiers will be blowing up
well nobody cares
but when i say one little old mayor will
die well then everyone loses their minds
amazing is that jared leto no no no no
no no
no but it was great writing and you're
gonna get in trouble for that one i
don't watch it
but it was it was writing to me he wrote
movies like it was it was good writing
for me especially because of the war
comment like that if you go to the media
and say a truckload of soldiers will be
blown up no one cares and it is
disgusting it is it is messed up that
society just like steamrolls over the
stuff that obama actually killed a 16
year old american citizen without charge
or trial and there was never any
tribunal nope there was no criminal
charges imagine that you could be the
president just kill american citizens
look first of all he was killing
children it's bad enough you want to
make an argument about war sure but
bombing a civilian restaurant and
killing an american kid
and there was nothing
nothing
that's messed up
and then i love it when people are like
obama was great
didn't joe joe rogan recently call him
like the greatest president or whatever
well it's yeah i wouldn't be shocked
that's very sad speaking of really
horrific things that go on in the world
that people don't really pay attention
to and aren't bothered by i mentioned
earlier we just did a video for freedom
tunes on yemen and the fact that the us
has been aiding the saudis in carrying
out a genocide where
an estimated 85 000 children under the
age of five have starved to death
because of the blockades that our
government has been supporting it's
really disgusting horrible stuff but
it's part of the plan i have a
correction joe did not say he was the
greatest president he said michelle
obama she's intelligent articulate she's
the wife of the best president that we
have had in our lifetime in terms of
like a representative of intelligent
articulate people she could win okay so
that's very very limited relative to
saying you're just like the best
president yemen is where obama bombed uh
awlaki's anwar allah's son is that what
it is abdulrahman al-awlaki just say his
name you don't need to say someone's son
yeah i didn't know his name is the
father i don't care abdulrahman abdul
rahman and that was in yemen so this
year he was born i think he was born in
boulder was living in san diego he went
to visit family in yemen and he was
sitting with his dad in the restaurant
is that what it is that was in the
building next door he was not with his
dad his dad i believe was already dead
wow because obama also killed anwar
al-awlaki who was an american citizen
without charges obama i think he did he
state that he did it just to get at the
guy's family no his response was
whoopsie
i
i think i was listening to drinking bros
and they were saying that when someone
when a civilian gets hit it's never an
issue of precision it's an issue of
intelligence so when they hit someone
it's because that's who they intended to
hit they just might have been wrong
about what they did which is very
stunning indictment of the opening the
the statement was that they were trying
to target some other guy and they hit
the wrong one i don't think so i think
the statement was if you're a terrorist
will kill your children did he say he
should have a better dad that was i
think that was charlie gibbs to luke
luke was at uh dnc was it dnc it was
like a debate in 2012 2012. i don't know
if it was luke or um
i can't remember who else was with the
misera maybe but uh
someone asked you know what he have to
say obama killed a six-year-old and the
guy was like i think it was charlie
gibbs well he should have had a better
dad or maybe that was peter king i'm not
sure extrajudicial assassinations bad
news dude this patriot act things got to
go so and you want to talk about the
constitution that was 10 years ago that
luke was interviewing people about this
stuff barack obama
killed american citizens without charge
or trial and he's never been held
accountable for it
now you can argue about trump all day
now you want to bring me the indictments
against trump i'll read them how about
you know you do that then grant then we
come back and then uh
we talk about obama too yeah we got luke
in chat
did uh did luke mention i see that i see
your your latest chat loop i don't see
your password she says he said he should
have had a better father yeah
sense of the father man kill a kid
i i that's just so disgusting man
so disgusting yeah all right
vosh says you're wrong tim read the
fountain head
i started to read atlas shrugged and
then i just watched the movie
that's even worse it is absolutely
that's terrible but then what happened
was i got i got about 40 minutes into
the movie and then i decided just to
play bioshock instead
bioshock's awesome you're going to get
iron philosophy either way that's right
atlas is the bad guy in bioshock you
actually fight atlas but it's not like
from the book bioshock's so cool what a
great game dude
would you kindly
that's so so good you guys know what i'm
talking about
all right
jason mcneil says i could have paid 20k
to go and learn to use heavy equipment i
instead found a company who has been
happy to train me and i get paid for it
cool one of my favorite stories is that
back in my uh old neighborhood there was
a dude who uh
he applied for a job at a warehouse as a
like a a forklift operator because it
paid like six figures but he was a high
school dropout or something and then
when he got there they were like all
right so you're going to be using you
know the this reg and he went oh well
i've never used that one before and
they're like yeah it's fine we'll train
you
got a six figure job just like that
that's awesome
it's funny in it that's cool they'll
also train you if you need like a
security clearance and you go into a job
where it's required they can help you
get that too
drago says they removed elk boys and
trump podcasts 6 million in 24 hours
yep so let me get this straight if we do
a podcast with trump and i just argue
with them we're good
as long as you sit there and say
no that is not accurate this is what's
real exactly but you have to say that
over and over tim you can't be like no
you're much more competent and handsome
than you're saying
we had bannon here and he made similar
statements and i argued with him i told
him he was wrong and i was like
like now we have to get into it because
you said it and i'm going to tell you
but i genuinely do think trump is wrong
i think like
when i hear the fraud narrative the
rigged election stuff i'm just like
whatever you believe you are
discouraging people from getting out and
getting in these primaries and i don't
know why you're doing it you know but
but i genuinely think this is a weakness
of trump supporters where instead of
believing they were beat by
as time magazine called it the shadow
campaign
through mass mail in voting through just
ground game getting out there and
advocating going to you know going to
old folks homes and hear your mailing
ballots now came in the mail make sure
everybody fills them out they're just
like nah it had to be rigged it's the
only way trump could have lost and i'm
like or they took away sports they took
away movies they took away going out
with your family they beat you over the
head non-stop at the media and then they
mailed you a ballot and say you want
things go back to normal there it is and
people went okay
that's what i think happened
anyway
all right let's see what we got here
let's get some more weird times says 25
of americans attend college they are the
highest paid people on earth why does
kim think the 75 of those
why does kim make the 75 percent of
those who did attend college what is it
maybe what and didn't is what they meant
to put in there like what did you think
of the 75 didn't attend college
yeah
well like i
can't really speculate so there we go
bro uh let's say brock says i joined the
military at 18 got out and worked for
two years then went to a local community
college and got a degree in commuter
computer aided drafting i have an
amazing career now trade school for the
win
nice well although is that trade school
if you go to community college
i don't know i don't know i'm gonna look
i don't know
i'm curious too
not the bomb says third super chat ever
never been read to tim's point i work on
semis i went to school for two years for
a piece of 18 000 for a piece of 18 000
paper i have learned more working than
ever in class 18k feels wasted
according to brave community colleges
not trade school they're different they
can get you ready for it i think i don't
know
a book of cloud says from chicken city
we salute you of great and powerful
chicken overlord tim
that's right chicken city
we've got over 7 000 subs on chicken
city oh wow that's fast fast growing
show when did you start this one this
this week earlier this weekend yeah yeah
well they are entertaining
the drama there is some drama in there i
was watching i was watching and you know
they calm for a little while and then
somebody does something to somebody and
there's a squabble right and it's like
they're all fighting chicken fighting
pecking order yeah
we have a night vision of all the
chickens sleeping that's right chicken
city
yeah they're all sleeping uh in their
little oh my gosh they are
backwards
they're not supposed to be sleeping up
there we built them fancy chicken houses
oh that's awesome but they chose to go
there instead because they are not smart
and they don't know
that they have nicer spots to go well
what we were supposed to do is actually
put them in the chicken house every
night and like close it until they learn
that they actually have a proper chicken
nesting thing we built that goes really
high oh they're chickens so
you know dude shout out to orion galaxy
and ham sandwich in the chicken city
chat
that's right go subscribe to chicken
city
all right we'll just get this one more
cornelius butt knuckle says tim is right
most degrees are pointless i've recently
used the knowledge i've picked up as a
machinist of 10 years to design and make
a jet engine that burns used isopropyl
to propel a pontiac bonneville up to 50
miles an hour never went to college for
machining or engineering that sounds
amazing cool but are you getting a job
to do that
you know like yeah you could build one
in your garage and stuff but are you
actually going to be employed by a
company that is going to ask you to
actually engineer that and put that into
a piece of machinery that somebody's
going to risk their life
while driving well if you're looking for
a job about you know making an alcohol
powered bonneville you're probably going
to hire more like mythbusters
or a sci-fi special effects or industry
you know i don't think he's gonna go
work for pontiac
yeah well but also i think just the
skills he developed as a mechanic might
help him in other
careers he might pursue
related automobiles not necessarily that
he is going to be doing that exact thing
for a living all right my friends if you
haven't already smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends if you really do like
it because it's the most powerful thing
you can do
we we're not going to put up billboards
or anything or i don't know maybe we
should you know just do what cnn doesn't
put billboards everywhere i guess but uh
also
search for chicken city on youtube and
subscribe and you can watch chickens but
guess what periodically i yell and
scream outside the window and you'll
hear me yelling at chickens i heard you
yelling earlier at the chat yeah i've
done them several times that's funny and
then you like when i yell at roberto and
then i watch the stream and i see him
like that perks up like what who's
yelling so uh check out chicken city
in order to get so here's our plan
we're gonna make it so that
if you super chat a certain amount or
super chats a certain amount of
superchat is reached treats come down in
order to get there we need to be
monetized unless we use streamlabs which
maybe we'll do because it's probably got
a better api anyway
and then
all right so the issue there is for some
reason i guess live streams don't count
toward public viewer hours so it's hard
to get monetized we'll figure it out but
also go to tipcast.com be a member we're
gonna have that member segment coming up
for you at 11. you can follow the show
at tim cast irl you can follow me at tim
cast do you want to shout anything out
kim
shout out hey
oh gosh um you can find me on twitter at
kim iverson show or youtube just go to
kim
iversonshow.com and you'll find it and
that's said with an e s e or o if you
spell it either way i have all of these
yeah
that way you can't get confused nice
yeah
yeah you can find my work at freedom
tunes we release a new educational
cartoon or piece of political satire
every single week on thursdays sometimes
one on tuesday so we actually released
two videos this week the one on tuesday
was satirical the one we released today
was educational i think you guys will
really enjoy it if you go there and
check it out uh ian crossland ian
crossland.net i mentioned at the
beginning of the show but i'll say it
again i'm looking for an open source uh
ux ui designer if you want to get in
touch with me on twitter on mines just
message me and let me know we're working
with our charity that we're starting up
building decentralized social media
software if you're not familiar with it
i'll tell you more about it later see
you later cool beans as far as chicken
city is concerned someone earlier today
tweeted me a picture of their cat
watching chicken city bradley i thought
that was adorable if it's nothing but a
cat watching channel i think that's
fantastic so let's get it going go over
there and subscribe cool stuff going on
over there you guys may follow me on
twitter and at mines.com at
sourpatchlits
that's right i'm just watching chicken
city
it's engrossed i'm afraid they're gonna
do the feeding thing that they're gonna
get really fast no it'll it'll only be
able to operate like five times per day
okay so it'll be a limited amount of
treats yeah and we have a lot of
chickens we're about to we're about to
have uh 56 more babies gosh so
we're not all we're not going to put
them all in we might actually just give
the some of the babies away to people
who might want them so we'll maybe if
like a member's only thing
yeah like if you're a member you can
like sign up like i would like a baby
chick and then will i put a little box
with you know that one this one
chicken's sleeping standing up yeah
that's roberto junior wow he's a beast
that's right all right everybody we will
see you all over at timcast.com around
11 p.m thanks for hanging out bye guys
you